Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. Olaf and Harald crashed into the enemy line like a storm ripping into a forest. Men were falling on every side, shards and splinters and splatters of blood flying into their faces. But soon the Norwegians were pressing back, using their numbers to hem Olaf's men in, squeezing them, crushing them together. More missiles rained down, spears, arrows, and throwing axes.
感谢收听《一切皆历史》（The Rest is History）。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。奥拉夫（Olaf）和哈拉尔（Harald）如同一场狂风撕裂森林般冲入敌阵。四处都有人倒下，碎片、木屑和飞溅的鲜血喷洒在他们的脸上。但不久后，挪威人开始反击，他们凭借人数优势将奥拉夫的手下包围，挤压他们，将他们撞成一团。更多的飞弹如雨般落下，长矛、箭矢和投掷斧。
The ground was slippery with blood. For a moment Harald lost his footing, but then a hand was dragging him back up, and Ulf the Icelander flashed him a grim smile. Olaf raised his voice again, rallying his men for another charge, the sea serpent waving proudly overhead. Yet in the corner of his eye, Harald could see the terrifying figure of Thorir the Hound, his teeth bared with savage laughter, his black spear dripping with blood, cutting through the crowd towards his brother.
地面被鲜血浸得湿滑。哈拉尔有一瞬间失去了平衡，但随后一只手将他拉了起来，冰岛人乌尔夫（Ulf）向他露出一抹冷酷的微笑。奥拉夫再次提高音量，重整队伍准备再次冲锋，海蛇旗在头顶骄傲地飘扬。然而，在眼角的余光中，哈拉尔看到令人恐惧的“猎犬”托里尔（Thorir the Hound）的身影，他露齿狞笑，黑色的长矛上滴着鲜血，在人群中向他的兄弟杀开一条血路。
And it was now, as the battle hung in the balance, that the heavens proclaimed their verdict. So that unbelievably manly and buccaneering prose is from Adventures in Time, Fury of the Vikings, Dominic's excellent book on the Vikings. And it describes one of the many thrilling scenes from the life of Harold Hardrada, who will go on to become one of the stars of the great drama of 1066. But Dominic, this is not a description of a battle fought in 1066, but in 1930. And it's the battle of Stiklestad in Norway, one of the most celebrated events
正是在这个时候，当战局悬而未决之际，苍天宣判了结果。这段无比具有男子气概且充满海盗风范的文字出自多米尼克（Dominic）关于维京人的优秀著作《时间历险：维京人的愤怒》（Adventures in Time, Fury of the Vikings）。它描述了哈拉尔·哈德拉达（Harold Hardrada）一生的许多惊心动魄的场景之一，他后来将成为1066年宏大历史大剧的主角之一。但多米尼克，这不是对1066年战役的描述，而是1930年的描述。这是挪威的斯蒂克兰德战役（Battle of Stiklestad），是挪威历史上最著名的事件之一
in the history of Norway and particularly of Norwegian Christianity. But we will come onto that in due course. So Dominic, Harold Tardrada, two episodes on the Thunderbolt of the North, as Adam of Bremen called him, the last Viking, the greatest warrior of his day. Take him away. Yeah. So Tom, we've done a lot of great characters in the rest of history, but I think Harold Hardrada has a claim to be the most exciting. Certainly his life is the most dramatic and unexpected. So you and I, when we studied 1066 at school, yeah, Howard Hardrada is really
特别是在挪威基督教历史上。但我们将在适的时候谈到这一点。那么，多米尼克，哈拉尔·哈德拉达（Harold Hardrada），两集关于布莱曼·亚当（Adam of Bremen）所称的“北方雷霆”节目，最后的维京人，他那个时代最伟大的战士。请为我们讲述吧。好的。那么，汤姆，我们在《一切皆历史》中讲述过很多伟大的角色，但我认为哈拉尔·哈德拉达绝对有资格被称为最令人兴奋的一个。当然，他的一生是最具戏剧性和出乎意料的。所以你和我，当我们当年在学校学习1066年历史时，是的，哈拉尔·哈德拉达其实
an exciting supporting character, isn't he? He's one of the three contenders in the great game of Thrones arrives suddenly in the middle of 1066. He crosses the North sea. He leads an army into York and then he faces Harold Goldwinson in this sort of thrilling showdown at Stanford Bridge. But his story before that is so colourful that I think, I would be interested to know
是一个激动人心的配角，对吧？他是权力游戏（Game of Thrones）中三位争夺者之一，在1066年中期突然出现。他横渡北海。他率领军队进入约克（York），然后在斯坦福桥（Stanford Bridge）面临哈拉尔·戈德温森（Harold Godwinson）这种惊心动魄的决战。但在此之前，他的经历是如此丰富多彩，以至于我认为，我很想知道
what you think, I think it's surely a contender for the most exciting life in medieval history. Well as written several, I mean a couple of centuries later. So definitely ornamented, but the basic outline of it, I agree, is astonishing. And we did an episode before on the Vikings going eastwards and we talked about the strangeness of, it's kind of like two different periods of history rubbing up against one another, the Viking age and the Roman age, because you have Harold walking around Constantinople and we've been doing this series on, focused very much on England and the North Sea and Northern France. But there are all kinds of links to the Mediterranean, to the Byzantine Empire, to the Holy Land that we will be exploring over the course of these episodes looking at Harold
你的看法，我认为这绝对是中世纪历史上最令人兴奋的一生的有力竞争者。好吧，正如几个世纪后所写的那样。所以这肯定经过了润色，但其基本轮廓，我同意，是令人惊叹的。我们之前做过一集关于维京人向东进发的节目，我们讨论了那种奇特性，这有点像是两个不同的历史时期相互碰撞，即维京时代和罗马时代，因为哈拉尔在君士坦丁堡四处游走，而我们一直在做的这个系列，非常专注于英格兰、北海和法国北部。但其中有各种各样的联系，通往地中海、拜占庭帝国、圣地，我们将在接下来的节目中探讨这些内容，来看看哈拉尔·哈德拉达
Andrade's life. Exactly. So to give people just a little preview. He fights that first battle when he's a teenager. He flees Norway into exile. He ends up as a mercenary for the Grand Prince of Kievan Rus'. He crosses the Black Sea to Constantinople. He joins the Varangian Guard. He fights everywhere from Sicily to Armenia. He becomes engulfed, quite literally, in the snake pit of Constantinople politics. One might say the dragon pit.
的一生。没错。为了给听众一个小小的剧透。他在十几岁时就经历了第一场战斗。他逃离挪威去流亡。他最终成为基辅罗斯（Kievan Rus'）大公的雇佣兵。他横渡黑海前往君士坦丁堡。他加入了瓦兰吉安卫队（Varangian Guard）。他在从西西里到亚美尼亚的各地作战。他字面意义上陷入了君士坦丁堡政治的蛇坑之中。人们甚至可以说那是龙坑。
Exactly. And then he returns to claim the throne of Norway. So it's a very kind of Aragorn trajectory. The guy who disappears into exile as a sort of mercenary or a ranger from the north and then returns to reclaim his throne. Although he's a bit more kind of brutal, isn't he? Yes. Aragorn.
没错。然后他回到挪威索取王位。所以这是一种非常类似阿拉贡（Aragon）的轨迹。一个作为雇佣兵或北方游侠消失在流亡中的家伙，然后回来夺回他的王位。虽然他有点更残暴，对吧？是的。阿拉贡。
A bit more wading through the blood of other people, I think it's fair to say. But I think there are two important dimensions of it, sort of more seriously. So one is, as you've said, it is a brilliant reminder of the interconnectedness of this world. So 11th century Europe. So these trading networks, cultural networks,
我觉得可以公平地说，他更多地涉足于其他人的鲜血之中。但从更严肃的角度来看，我认为有两个重要的维度。首先，正如你所说，它是这个世界互联互通的一个极好的提醒。也就是11世纪的欧洲。这些贸易网络、文化网络、
political and so on, that link the fjords of Norway to the Black Sea, the Mediterranean, the Middle East and so on. These are not completely different spheres of action. People move between them. Right. And the great silver hoards that you get in Viking Scandinavia, they're not just coming from England. They're also coming from Byzantium and from the Caliphate. These much richer parts of the world, quite frankly. And then the other thing is you described him, as people do, as the last Viking. And you know, we'll discuss that in more detail later on.
政治网络等等，将挪威的峡湾与黑海、地中海、中东等联系在一起。这些并不是完全不同的活动领域。人们在它们之间穿梭。没错。你在维京斯堪的纳维亚发现的大量白银宝藏，不仅仅来自英格兰。它们也来自拜占庭和哈里发国。坦率地说，这些是世界上更富裕的地区。然后另一件事是，你像其他人一样把他描述为最后的维京人。你知道，我们稍后会更详细地讨论这一点。
And his life undoubtedly is a window into the last sort of embers of the Viking age. So a changing Scandinavia. We've hinted at this in the last series we did about the roads 1066. So the way in which villages are becoming towns, warlords are becoming Kings, pagans are becoming Christians. And the Viking age is passing into history and his life seems to be the perfect punctuation point, I would say. Now, the other point, we shouldn't perhaps labor too much.
他的一生无疑是了解维京时代最后余晖的一个窗口。也就是一个正在变化のス堪的纳维亚。我们在上一系列关于1066年道路的节目中已经暗示过这一点。村庄正在变成城镇，军阀正在变成国王，异教徒正在变成基督徒。维京时代正在成为历史，而他的一生似乎是一个完美的标点符号，我想这么说。现在，还有一点，我们也许不应该过分强调。
You've alluded to it. The best sources for his life are these sagas like Heimskringler, great saga, sometimes written by Snorri Sturluson, the great kind of saga writer, written in Iceland centuries later. What are we talking sort of 12th, 13th century sagas? So they're written long after the event. And as we will see, there are a lot of fictional and fantastical elements, which some scrupulous historians would cut.
你已经暗示过了。关于他一生的最佳资料是那些诸如《海姆斯kringla》（Heimskringla）之类的传奇故事，这是一部伟大的传奇，有时由伟大的传奇作家斯诺里·斯图鲁松（Snorri Sturluson）在几个世纪后于冰岛撰写。我们谈论的是大约12世纪、13世纪的传奇故事吗？所以它们是在事件发生很久之后才写的。正如我们所见，其中有很多虚构和奇幻的元素，一些一丝不苟的历史学家会把它们删掉。
They would do their best to eliminate from the podcast. We've done the opposite. Well, I've certainly done the opposite. I think it's best to play those up because Tom, as we always say, it's important to see the world as they saw it, isn't it? I suppose what I would say, we would see the world as snorri-stirlers. Right. And medieval Iceland would see it, whether that maps? I suppose what I would say, we would see the world as Snorri Sturluson. Right.
他们会尽最大努力将这些从播客中剔除。我们做了相反的事情。好吧，我当然做了相反的事情。我认为最好把这些放大，因为汤姆，正如我们经常说的，像他们那样看待世界是很重要的，不是吗？我想我要说的是，我们将以斯诺里·斯图鲁松的视角来看待世界。没错。中世纪的冰岛人会这样看，不管这是否契合？我想我要说的是，我们将以斯诺里·斯图鲁松的视角来看待世界。没错。
Medieval Iceland would see it, whether that maps on exactly to how Harold sees it. We will explore that. But the good news for everybody is this is a podcast and not a PhD. If you're hoping for giant serpents, you'll get them. Berserkers covered in birds screaming, you know, at the top of their voices. This is the podcast for you. But let's start in history with what we know of the historical Harold Sigurdsson. So he's born in the uplands of Norway, probably in 1015.
中世纪的冰岛人会看到它，这是否完全对应哈拉尔的看法。我们会探讨这一点。但对每个人来说的好消息是，这是一个播客，而不是哲学博士（PhD）论文。如果你希望看到巨型海蛇，你会如愿以偿。狂战士身上覆满鸟类，尖叫着，你知道，用最高音。这就是为你量身定制的播客。但让我们从历史开始，从我们所了解的历史人物哈拉尔·西居尔松（Harold Sigurdsson）说起。他出生在挪威的高地，大约在1015年。
His father is a kind of local king, what they call a petty king, a kind of regional big man. And his father had the brilliant name Sigurd Seer, Sigurd the sow. And he had this nickname, the sow, because he preferred farming to fighting. And sometimes people think, well, obviously this is derogatory. They imagine him as a kind of, you know, a lazy man who doesn't, you know, doesn't go out and smite, you know, his neighbors or whatever. But actually in the sagas, the portrait of Sigurd is quite generous.
他的父亲是一个地方国王，也就是所谓的土王（petty king），一种地区大人物。他的父亲有一个极其出色的名字，叫西居尔·西尔（Sigurd Sow），也就是“母猪西居尔”。他有这个绰号“母猪”，是因为他比起打仗更喜欢务农。有时人们会想，嗯，这显然是贬义的。他们想象他是一个，你知道的，懒惰的人，不，你知道的，不出去打击，你知道的，他的邻居之类的人。但实际上在传奇故事中，对西居尔的描写是相当慷慨的。
And I quote, he was a careful householder who kept his people closely to their work and often went about himself to inspect his crops and meadows, the cattle and the smithies. I mean, I imagine him as a kind of a slow moving, but you wouldn't want to annoy ox. Yeah, I think that's fair. Much loved by his by his vassals or whatever, I would imagine. Respected. They would put kind of daisy chains around his horns, but do not provoke his wrath.
我引用一下：“他是一个细心的家主，严格要求手下工作，并经常亲自去巡视庄稼和田野、牛群和铁匠铺。”我的意思是，我把他想象成那种行动缓慢，但你绝对不想惹毛的公牛。是的，我觉得这很公平。我想他会深受其封臣或其他人的喜爱。备受尊敬。他们会在他的角上戴上雏菊链，但千万不要激怒他的愤怒。
That kind of thing. And he is married to this woman called Ørsta. She's the widow of another kind of provincial bigwig in the Westfold of Norway. And she's had a son with this guy called Olaf the Stout. Now when Harald is born, so Olaf, his half brother, is about 20. He's going to play a massive part in Harold's life because Harold is going to hugely look up to him. So Olaf, we know more about Olaf at this point than we do Harold. Olaf has been involved in war from a very young age. Supposedly, according to the sagas, he first went into battle when he was 12 and he fought in Finland and Estonia.
诸如此类。他娶了一个名叫厄斯塔（Ørsta）的女子。她是挪威西福尔（Westfold）另一个地方大人物的遗孀。她和这个叫勇敢的奥拉夫（Olaf the Stout）的家伙生了一个儿子。现在，当哈拉尔出生时，奥拉夫（他的同母异父兄弟）大约20岁。他在哈拉尔的一生中将扮演极其重要的角色，因为哈拉尔将极其仰慕他。所以，关于奥拉夫，此时我们对他的了解比对哈拉尔的了解要多。奥拉夫从很小的时候就卷入了战争。据传奇故事记载，他据说在12岁时就首次投入战斗，并在芬兰和爱尔兰作战。
He was part of that Scandinavian horde who descended on England in the years of Aether Aethi and ready. So he served with this bloke Thorkell, the tall who we talked about last time. And he actually ended up was one of the people who was ended up as a mercenary fighting for Aether Aethi and ready. Yeah. He's the guy who supposedly pulls down London bridge Thereby inspiring the nursery rhyme. Now he's also spent time in Normandy, a place we talked a lot about last time, a crucial sort of node
他是那些在埃塞尔雷德（Aethelred the Unready）统治时期涌入英格兰斯堪的纳维亚暴民的一部分。所以他曾跟随我们上次谈到过的那个叫高个子托克尔（Thorkell the Tall）的家伙效力。他实际上最终成为了作为雇佣兵为埃塞尔雷德效力的人之一。是的。他就是那个据说推倒了伦敦桥的人，从而启发了童谣。现在他还曾在诺曼底待过，那是我们上次谈论过很多的一个地方，是北海和海峡两岸网络中的一个关键节点。
in the network across the sort of North Sea and the channel. He'd been baptized a Christian in Rouen and he later becomes a great champion or he's seen as a great champion of Christianity in Norway. But whether he's very as a great champion of Christianity in Norway. But whether he's very pious, I think is dubious. I think for him, Christianity is about power and about status and about generally smiting his enemies and making himself king. So Snorri says that his eyes are hard as serpents. Right. Jesus wouldn't like that, would he? It's more adventures in time, it has to be said. It is. His scalds, his poets said that he was the ember breaker of battle. He gave gold to his loyal men and
他在鲁昂（Rouen）受洗成为基督徒，后来成为挪威基督教的一个伟大捍卫者，或者被视为一个伟大的捍卫者。但至于他是否真的是挪威基督教的伟大捍卫者，我认为这是值得怀疑的。我认为对海勒来说，基督教关乎权力和地位，关乎普遍打击敌人并让自己成为国王。所以斯诺里说他的眼睛像蛇一样冷硬。没错。耶稣不会喜欢那样，对吧？必须承认，这更像是时间历险。确实如此。他的宫廷诗人们说他是战斗的余烬破坏者。他将黄金赐予忠诚的手下，
carrion to the ravens. That's what I like. I like that in a king. And actually in all the poems that were composed about him when he was alive, there's no mention of being kind or turning the other cheek. There's an awful lot of mention of like smashing people's heads in with hammers and stuff. So anyway, thanks to this head smashing, Olaf has actually stamped his authority on the different kind of strongmen of Norway. And around the time of Harald's birth, so 1015, he's recognized as the King of Norway. So another brilliant example of the way in which the Viking age is passing into history and being replaced by a kind of more ordered, more structured kind of world. We talked in the previous series about Olaf Trigforsen, this kind of sinister reader of bird bones. I mean, he establishes a Christian monarchy.
将腐肉赐予渡鸦。这就是我喜欢的。我喜欢国王有这种特质。实际上，在他生前为他创作的所有诗歌中，都没有提到善良或左脸被打转过右脸。有大量关于用锤子砸碎别人的脑袋之类的内容。不管怎样，多亏了这种砸脑袋的行为，奥拉夫实际上在挪威的各个强人中确立了自己的权威。在哈拉尔出生前后，也就是1015年左右，他被承认是挪威国王。因此，这又是维京时代正在消逝并被一种更有秩序、更有结构的时代所取代的一个绝佳例子。我们在前一个系列中讨论过奥拉夫·特里格弗森（Olaf Tryggvason），这个阴险的鸟骨预言者。我的意思是，他建立了一个基督教君主国。
He does it by committing spectacular atrocities in the name of Christ. And I think Harold Sigurdsson is cut from similar cloth very much in that kind of name of Christ. And I think Harold Sigurdsson is cut from similar cloth very much in that kind of line of descent. So Harold at this point, he's still in a little boy. Our first anecdote about him as a boy is in 1018 or so, his father has died, so Sigurd has died, and Olaf comes to visit his mother. So this sort of early 20s guy who's become king, his half-brother, he comes to visit their hall in a place called Ringariki. And the story is that Harold is there with his older brothers, Gothorm and Halfdan, and they're very shy of their relative, the king,
他通过以基督的名义犯下骇人听闻的暴行来实现这一点。我认为哈拉尔·西居尔松（Harold Sigurdsson）和他是同一货色，非常符合这种血统。所以此时的哈拉尔仍然是个小男孩。我们关于他作为男孩的第一个轶事发生在1018年左右，他的父亲已经去世，也就是西居尔死了，奥拉夫来拜访他的母亲。所以这个20岁出头、已经成为国王的同母异父兄弟，来到他们位于一个叫林格里克（Ringariki）的地方的大厅拜访。故事说，哈拉尔和他的哥哥们戈特霍姆（Gothorm）和哈夫丹（Halfdan）在那里，他们对他们的亲戚——国王感到非常害羞，
and they can't meet his eye. They have the hearts of girls. They do. But Harold, who is three years old, sits on Olaf's lap and tugs his mustache. The mark of a king. Yeah, Olaf says, brother, you will be a fighter one day. And then the next day, Olaf is walking with his mother. They're having a chat in the sort of the fields and they come across the boys playing by the stream and the other boys are playing as farmers.
他们不敢直视他的眼睛。他们有着女孩的心思。确实如此。但三岁的哈拉尔坐在奥拉夫的膝盖上，拉扯他的胡子。国王的标志。是的，奥拉夫说：“兄弟，你有一天会成为一名战士。”然后第二天，奥拉夫和他的母亲一起散步。他们在田野里聊天，偶然遇到了在小溪边玩耍的男孩们，其他男孩都在扮演农民。
But Harold Hardrada, the future Harold Hardrada, is sort of playing with long ten long ships and Olaf says to him by the day may come brother when you command real ships And then he says to them and I'm sure this definitely happened Tom. He says what would you like? what would you like most in life and Gotham says I would like a lot of fields and half Dan says I would like cows and Harold's age three says house calls So many they would eat all half Dan's cows at a single feast and Olaf says to Orster his mother He says well well mother you are bringing up a king So this is all very impressive and I'm sure that this all happened
但哈拉尔·哈德拉达，未来的哈拉尔·哈德拉达，却在摆弄十艘长船。奥拉夫对他说：“兄弟，也许有一天你会指挥真正的战船。”然后他对他们说——我确信这绝对发生过，汤姆。他说：“你最想要什么？你一生中最想要什么？”戈特霍姆说：“我想要很多田地。”哈夫丹说：“我想要牛。”而三岁的哈拉尔说：“豪宅和家畜。”“多到能在单一的盛宴上吃光哈夫丹所有的牛。”奥拉夫对他的母亲厄斯塔说：“好吧，好吧，母亲，你正在抚养一个国王。”所以这一切都非常令人印象深刻，我相信这一切都发生了。
But actually all the sources agree and there's no reason to doubt them that Harold is an exceptionally formidable character. So Snorri Sturluson in King Harold's saga says, Harold was a handsome man of noble appearance, his hair and beard yellow. He had a short beard and long moustaches. Peculiarly, the one eyebrow was somewhat higher than the other. So he's kind of Roger Moore like in that respect.
但实际上，所有资料都一致认为，而且没有理由怀疑它们，哈拉尔是一个极其令人生畏的人物。因此，斯诺里·斯图鲁松在《哈拉尔国王传奇》（King Harold’s saga）中说：“哈拉尔是一个相貌堂堂、仪态高贵的男子，他的头发和胡须是黄色的。他留着短须和长八字胡。奇特的是，他的一只眉毛比另一只稍高一些。”所以他在这一点上有点像罗杰·摩尔（Roger Moore）。
He can raise an eyebrow at a Merry quip. Yeah, he's brutal, but suave. Suave, exactly. His height was five L's. He was stern and severe to his enemies and cruelly punished all oppositional misdeed. So five L's, as the story points out, that would make him seven and a half feet tall. And the sources do say he's very, very tall, but he's probably not seven and a half feet.
他能在听到俏皮话时挑起一根眉毛。是的，他很残酷，但温文尔雅。温文尔雅，没错。他的身高是五“埃尔”（L's）。他对敌人严厉而严苛，并残酷惩罚所有反对派的恶行。因此，正如故事所指出的，五“埃尔”将使他身高七英尺半。资料确实说他非常非常高，但他可能没有七英尺半。
I mean, the one thing that people know is that Stamford bridge at the battle of Stamford bridge, he says of Harold Gobbinson, what a small man. But also Harold then turns it, doesn't he? And makes a famous joke about his height, which we will come to. Yes, exactly. Of course. He's definitely a huge man. I don't have any doubt about that.
我的意思是，人们都知道的一件事是，在斯坦福桥战役中，他对哈拉尔·戈德温森（Harold Godwinson）说：“多么矮小的男人。”但随后哈拉尔也扭转了局面，不是吗？并且开了一个关于他身高的著名玩笑，我们稍后会讲到。是的，绝对如此。他绝对是个身材高大的人。对此我毫无疑问。
And he's good looking because one of the other names that he gets as well as Hardrada is fair hair. Yes. So he's blonde haired. He's incredibly impressive. And the portrait we get of him generally, I think in the sagas captures that last of the Vikings feel. There's definitely a sort of, he's huge.
他长得很帅，因为除了“哈德拉达”之外，他得到的另一个名字是“金发”（fair hair）。是的。他是金发。他令人印象深刻。而且我们普遍对他得到的画像，我认为在传奇故事中捕捉到了那种最后的维京人的感觉。这绝对有一种，他身材高大。
He's ruthless. He loves gold. He likes fighting and the saga's always have him. There's a brilliant book called laughing till I die by Tom Shippey, the great kind of expert on kind of Norse and Anglo-Saxon literature is written a lot about Tolkien Tom Shippey says one of the defining things about Harold Hardrada in the saga is he's always making quips and composing poems in the face of danger and stuff. The Vikings took that, that's very much a Viking sensibility, that, you know, there's a fatalism coupled with a sort of
他冷酷无情。他热爱黄金。他喜欢打仗，而且传奇故事总是把他描绘成这样。有一本精彩的书叫《笑到我死》（laughing till I die），作者是汤姆·希佩（Tom Shippey），他是北欧和盎格鲁-萨克逊文学的伟大专家，写了很多关于托尔金的文章。汤姆·希佩说，传奇故事中哈拉尔·哈德拉达的一个决定性特征是，他总是面对危险时妙语连珠并即兴赋诗。维京人接受了这一点，这非常具有维京人的敏感性，即一种宿命论加上一种
I laugh in the face of death, which I don't doubt because you can tell that from the way he behaves. I don't doubt that that's true to his character to some degree. Well, I mean, I guess the sagas preserve poetic traditions that definitely go back to the Viking age. And if this is part of the context in which Vikings are growing up, then they're going to model themselves on what they're reading in the epics. It's a kind of a virtuous circle. As he sits around the hearth, Tom, listening to the to the bards or the skulls kind of
笑对死亡的态度，对此我并不怀疑，因为你可以从他的行为中看出这一点。我不怀疑这在某种程度上符合他的性格。嗯，我的意思是，我猜传奇故事保留了绝对可以追溯到维京时代的诗歌传统。如果这是维京人成长背景的一部分，那么他们就会以史诗中读到的内容为榜样。这是一个良性循环。正如他坐在壁炉旁，汤姆，听着吟游诗人或宫廷诗人
telling their stories about Ragnar Lothbrok or whatever. He wants to live up to it. He wants to model himself on that. Exactly. The fact that they have become Christian, that they have become kings, that they can now command the vast resources almost of a kind of an emergent state doesn't make them less of Vikings. Because if you think of Canute or Svein Fortbeard, Canute's dad, they're Vikings on a terrifying
讲他们关于拉格纳·洛德布罗克（Ragnar Lothbrok）或类似的故事。他想不负期望。他想以之为榜样。没错。他们已经皈依基督教，他们已经成为了国王，他们现在几乎可以指挥一个新兴国家的庞大资源，这并没有让他们减少维京人的本色。因为如果你想想克努特（Canute）或“蓝牙”斯韦因（Sven Forkbeard，克努特的父亲），他们是具有可怕规模的维京人。
scale and there's that intersection point, isn't there, where Viking brutality and the resources available to a Christian King intersect. And it's very bad news for their neighbors. Yeah. So they're not really going on this piddling little raids anymore. What they're doing and launching proper invasions and seizing kingdoms and piling up gold on the skins of oxes. That's what they're doing.
而且存在那个交汇点，对吧？维京人的残酷与基督教国王可用的资源在那里交汇。这对他们的邻居来说是个非常糟糕的消息。是的。所以他们不再进行这种微不足道的小规模袭击了。他们在做的是发起真正的入侵，夺取王国，并在牛皮上堆积黄金。这就是他们在做的事情。
So he next appears in the Sarkis in the spring of 1030 when he's 15 years old. And a lot has changed since the days when he was, you know, tugging people's beards. So his brother Olaf, Olaf the Stout, this guy who'd united Norway, has had a massive falling out with Cnut, the King of Denmark and England, who we talked about in the last series. Now we know that Cnut and Olaf did know each other. Their paths had undoubtedly crossed in England back in the days of Svein Fortbeard and so on. And some Scandinavian historians think that
所以他在1030年春天的传奇故事中再次出现，当时他15岁。自从他扯人胡子的日子以来，很多事情都变了。他的兄弟奥拉夫，即勇敢的奥拉夫，这个统一了挪威的家伙，与丹麦和英格兰国王克努特（我们在上个系列中谈到过）发生了巨大的争执。现在我们知道克努特和奥拉夫确实认识对方。他们的道路毫无疑问在英格兰的“蓝牙”斯韦因等人的时代就已经交叉过了。一些斯堪的纳维亚历史学家认为，
what had basically happened is that Olaf had probably promised to be kind of Cnut's vassal and had reneged on the deal, which is a big theme of kind of Danish and Norwegian history. Well, because they fought each other on opposite sides in England. Exactly. So in 1028, so two years before 1030, Cnut had sailed from England with 50 warships and had actually been welcomed by the Norwegians with open arms. So it's pretty clear that in the north, in particular Norway, the local magnates actually didn't like Olaf and wanted him out. And Knut were told when the sagas had bribed them with enormous quantities of gold and silver. Every man who came to him and wished to be his friend had his hands filled with coins.
基本上发生的事情是奥拉夫可能曾承诺成为克努特的封臣，但后来背信弃义了，这是丹麦和挪威历史上的一个重大主题。嗯，因为他们在英格兰曾在对立的两边作战。没错。所以在1028年，也就是1030年的两年前，克努特带着50艘战舰从英格兰起航，实际上受到了挪威人张开双臂的欢迎。所以很明显，在北方，特别是挪威，当地的权贵其实并不喜欢奥拉夫，并希望他滚蛋。据传奇故事记载，克努特曾用大量的金银贿赂他们。每一个来找他并希望成为他朋友的人，手里都塞满了硬币。
So Olaf, Harald's brother, has fled. He flees over the mountains to Sweden with a handful of his closest friends and his son Magnus, who will come up again on Thursday. And from Sweden he took a ship across the Baltic and he vanished into the forests of what is now Russia. Now we'll come back later in this episode to this side of things. But basically for 200 years this has been the kind of wild east of the Viking world. They've got all this network of forts and towns and so on.
所以哈拉尔的兄弟奥拉夫已经逃跑了。他带着几个最亲密的朋友和他的儿子马格努斯（Magnus，我们周四还会提到他）翻越群山逃往瑞典。从瑞典，他乘船穿过波罗的海，消失在现在是俄罗斯的森林中。现在我们将在本集稍后回到这方面的事情。但基本上200年来，这里一直是维京世界的野蛮东方。他们拥有所有的堡垒和城镇网络等等。
They're going all the way down the rivers into Ukraine towards the Black Sea and Constantinople, which is obviously the capital of the Eastern Roman Empire. And Olaf has taken shelter, probably in Kiev with the Grand Prince Yaroslav of Kiev, who's basically of Scandinavian descent. And who will be a key figure in the story we're going to tell. So Olaf has been gone for two years. And then in the spring of 1030, a dramatic twist, one of many in the story. Word reaches Norway that Olaf is on his way back.
他们顺着河流一直向下进入乌克兰，走向黑海和君士坦丁堡，这显然是东罗马帝国的首都。奥拉夫已经在基辅找到了避难所，可能是在基辅大公雅罗斯拉夫（Yaroslav of Kiev）那里，他基本上是斯堪的纳维亚血统。他将是我们即将讲述的故事中的关键人物。所以奥拉夫已经离开两年了。然后在1030年春天，出现了一个戏剧性的转折，故事中的许多转折之一。消息传到挪威，说奥拉夫正在回来的路上。
He's got about 200 warriors who are kind of Slav mercenaries and Norwegian exiles. I mean, the phrase Slav mercenaries is never something you want to hear if you're a peaceful villager, is it? It's a phrase that you definitely want to be using on a podcast. When you're talking about Slav mercenaries, you're living the dream. So he goes back and he arrives in Sweden and the Swedish king who's called Onund Jacob, he gives him some more men and then he recruits some more troops in Sweden, some more Norwegian exiles and so on.
他大约有200名战士，是斯拉夫雇佣兵和挪威流亡者。我的意思是，“斯拉夫雇佣兵”这句话，如果你是一个爱好和平的村民，绝对是你永远不想听到的，不是吗？这是一个你绝对想在播客中使用的短语。当你谈论斯拉夫雇佣兵时，你正在过着梦想中的生活。所以他回去了，抵达了瑞典，瑞典国王名叫奥农德·雅各布（Onund Jacob），他又给了他一些人马，然后他在瑞典招募了更多的部队，更多的挪威流亡者等等。
And so Olaf has this force of about 2,500 men. And then Harold, his younger brother turns up. So Harold at this point is about 15 or 16 years old. Please brother, may I fight with you? I think his voice broke when he was about 8. Oh, maybe when he was 3. Playing with his Viking ships. I imagine he's pretty formidable.
因此奥拉夫拥有了一支大约2500人的部队。然后哈拉尔，他的弟弟出现了。所以此时的哈拉尔大约15或16岁。“求求你，哥哥，让我和你一起战斗吧！”我想他在大约8岁时变声。哦，也许是在他3岁时。玩他的维京战船时。我猜他相当令人畏惧。
Massively hairy? I think it's more, he's got a mane of blonde hair, so he tosses in the wind. I hope one day brother to have a moustache like yours. And he will. Well he will. Well hold on, hold on. Hold on. Actually, I can't believe I didn't read this out.
满脸长毛？我觉得更可能是，他有一头金色的鬃毛，在风中飞扬。“我希望有一天能像哥哥你一样留着八字胡。”他会的。好吧，他会的。等等，等等。等等。其实，我不敢相信我没有把这段读出来。
Snorri Sturluson says at this point he was very stout and manly as though full grown. As though full grown, Dominic. Yeah, but very stout and manly. What? So he's fat? No, because stout in these days. So Olaf the Stout is not that he's fat. It's actually that it's sort of sturdy like me.
斯诺里·斯图鲁松在此时说：“他非常健壮且有男子气概，仿佛已经成年。”仿佛已经成年，多米尼克。是的，但非常健壮且有男子气概。什么？所以他很胖？不，因为那个时代的“Stout”。所以“勇敢的奥拉夫”并不是说他胖。实际上它类似于像我这样结实。
So right. Harald has raised a couple of hundred men from the uplands of central Norway. He's crossed the mountain spine of Scandinavia and he's gone down to Sweden to meet his brother. So they all assemble and then they decide they'll set off back to Norway and they're hoping to get more recruits as they go and they cross the spine again through the passes into the Norwegian uplands. Now there are some accounts, because this is the age of Christianization, that say that Olaf forced recruits to be baptized and he made them paint white crosses on their shields. We must depend on God, only with his power and mercy shall we gain victory and I cannot
所以，没错。哈拉尔从挪威中部的高地上召集了几百人。他穿过了斯堪的纳维亚的山脊，下到瑞典去见他的兄弟。所以他们都集结起来，然后他们决定启程回挪威，并希望在途中招募更多的新兵，他们通过山口再次穿过山脊进入挪威高地。现在有一些说法，因为这是基督教化的时代，说奥拉夫强迫新兵接受洗礼，并让他们在盾牌上画白色的十字。“我们必须依靠上帝，只有凭借他的力量和仁慈，我们才能赢得胜利，我不能
have pagan men in my army. But actually, most of the historians' accounts that I've read of this say this is probably nonsense that actually this is a back projection by later Christian chroniclers and that actually almost certainly it's a mixture of all kinds of random people in this army at this point. I would be less skeptical about it because he has seen London. He's seen Keefe. He's seen Christian Kings and the power that they command.
让异教徒留在我的军队里。”但实际上，我读过的绝大多数历史学家对此的记述都说这可能是无稽之谈，实际上这更像是后来基督教编年史家的倒填年代，几乎可以肯定，这支军队此时是由各种各样随机的人组成的。我对这一说法持较少怀疑的态度，因为他见过伦敦。他见过基辅。他见过基督教国王及其所掌握的权力。
And I think that everything about would be Viking Kings in this period suggests that they want a part of it. Oh, they do. I'm not saying that he doesn't shout about Christ and have a cross. What I'm saying is his very ragtag army. I don't think it has the quality of a crusade. No, it doesn't have a quality of the crusade, but the possibility that he makes him put white crosses on their shields or whatever.
我认为这一时期的准维京国王的一切都表明他们想要分一杯羹。噢，他们确实想。我不是说他不大声谈论基督并带着十字架。我说的是他那支非常杂牌的军队。我不认为它具备十字军东征的质量。不，它不具备十字军东征的品质，但他在他们的盾牌上画白色十字架或类似东西的可能性。
I mean, it's certainly possible. Yeah. Anyway, they come down into the height of summer, 1030, and they come down into the most fertile bits of Norway, which is called the Trondelag and surround the city that we now know as Trondheim, which at the time was called Nideros. And they're going through this valley and at the end of the valley is the village of Stiklestad, Stiklestad farm. And this is the setting for this great battle, probably the most famous battle in Norwegian history. I don't know how many Norwegian listeners we have, but they'll be very excited
我的意思是，这当然是可能的。无论如何，他们在1030年的盛夏下山，来到了挪威最肥沃的土地，被称为特伦德拉格（Trondelag），围绕着我们现在称为特隆赫姆（Trondheim）的城市，当时被称为尼德罗斯（Nideros）。他们穿过这个山谷，山谷的尽头是斯蒂克兰德村（Stiklestad），斯蒂克兰德农场。这里就是这场大战的背景，可能是挪威历史上最著名的战役。我不知道我们有多少挪威听众，但他们一定会对此感到非常兴奋。
about this. And as they advance down this valley, they see at the end a huge army waiting for them. So this army, their enemies, these are A, Cnut loyalists and B, basically local farmers and local peasants who hate Olaf and they are horrified that all these Slav mercenaries have turned up and they're about to pillage their lands and sort of you know attack their families and stuff. Do we know if Harold's brothers who were the farmers? Oh my word! You know do you think they've turned out? I think they've disappeared from the story Gothorm and Halfdan. I don't think they've turned out no no no. Because they wouldn't welcome Slavic mercenaries descending on there. They wouldn't but that's actually too busy tending their crops Tom. They've got no time for this kind of nonsense.
当他们沿着山谷前进时，他们看到尽头有一支庞大的军队在等着他们。所以这支军队，他们的敌人，这些是A，克努特的忠诚者，以及B，基本上是讨厌奥拉夫的当地农民和当地农夫，他们惊恐地发现所有这些斯拉夫雇佣兵都出现了，他们即将掠夺他们的土地并，你知道的，袭击他们的家人之类的事。我们知道哈拉尔的兄弟们是不是农民吗？哦，天哪！你知道，你觉得他们出场了吗？我认为戈特霍姆和哈夫丹已经从故事中消失了。我不认为他们出场了，不，不，不。因为他们不会欢迎斯拉夫雇佣兵降临到那里。他们不会的，但那是因为他们太忙于照料庄稼了，汤姆。他们没有时间搞这种无聊的把戏。
Now in the sagas, there are some absolutely splendid people involved in the enemy army. So the head of it, the head of this kind of loyalist army is a local strongman called Kalf Arneson, who's a sort of Canute loyalist. Then there's a bloke called Thorstein the Shipwright, and he has a grudge against Olaf because Olaf confiscated a ship from him as punishment for murdering somebody. Snorri Sturluson says that Thorstein the shipwright was quote very ardent and a skilled killer
现在在传奇故事中，敌军中确实有一些绝对光彩夺目的人物。所以它的首领，这支保王党军队的首领是一个名叫卡尔夫·阿尔内松（Kalf Arneson）的当地强人，他是克努特的忠实追随者。然后有一个家伙叫造船匠托尔斯坦（Thorstein the Shipwright），他对奥拉夫怀恨在心，因为奥拉夫没收了他的一艘船，作为惩罚他谋杀某人的代价。斯诺里·斯图鲁松说，造船匠托尔斯坦引用自“非常热心且是一个熟练的杀手
of men. That's nice. Which is nice. But by far the most terrifying person who you mentioned in that wonderful reading at the beginning of the show is this guy who's called Thorir the Hound and Thorir the Hound, I'm sure he existed. He's a warlord from the northern coast of Norway. So he's been in touch with the Sami people and he's wreathed in mystery and magic. He's a sorcerer as well as a hound. Well this is the kind of figure that Neil Price talks about. Yeah. Great book, the Viking way. And he came and talked about Viking sorcery and his great
的人。”这很好。这很好。但到目前为止，你在节目开始时的精彩朗读中提到过的那个人，是最令人恐惧的人物，这个家伙名叫“猎犬”托里尔（Thorir the Hound），“猎犬”托里尔，我确信他存在。他是挪威北部海岸的一个军阀。所以他一直与萨米人有联系，并且笼罩在神秘和魔法之中。他既是一个巫师，也是一只猎犬。嗯，这就是尼尔·普赖斯（Neil Price）谈论的那种人物。是的。伟大的书《维京之路》（The Viking way）。他来谈论过维京巫术，他伟大的
thesis is that so much of Viking culture is influenced by shamanistic traditions from the far north. That's a very fashionable view. Those net Tom. I like it. Yeah. I really, really like it. This bloke bears it out. He's wearing a Sami cloak of 12 reindeer skins with and I quote So much magic that no weapon could pierce them and if people doubt that We will have evidence for it later on in this story. He's got good medicine. He's also got a magic spear He's got a magic spear and he said, you know, I would use this magic spear to kill olaf Now they outnumber olaf's men four to one and they are absolutely pumped. They are gagging for battle.
论点是，维京文化的很大一部分受到来自远北的萨满教传统的启发。这是一个非常时髦的观点。那些网，汤姆。我喜欢它。真的，真的很喜欢。这个家伙就证明了这一点。他穿着一件由12张驯鹿皮制成的萨米斗篷，并且我引用“具有如此强大的魔法，以至于没有任何武器能刺穿它们，如果人们对此怀疑，我们稍后在这个故事中会有证据。”他有着强大的法术。他还有一把魔法长矛。他有一把魔法长矛，他说，“我会用这把魔法长矛杀死奥拉夫。”现在他们在人数上以四比一压倒奥拉夫的人马，而且他们斗志昂扬。他们渴望战斗。
Kalf Arneson, he raises his banner and he addresses his men and he says, He who does not fight bravely today shall be held a worthless coward. Spare none, for they will not spare you. Now Olaf, who's massively outnumbered, he raises his banner. You mentioned it in the reading, the sea serpent. He unsheathes his sword, which is called H'Nightir, striker, and he gives his own speech. Of course he does.
卡尔夫·阿尔内松举起他的旗帜，向他的手下发表讲话，他说：“今天作战不勇敢的人将被视为一无是处的懦夫。不留活口，因为他们也不会饶过你们。”现在，寡不敌众的奥拉夫举起了他的旗帜。你在朗读中提到了它，那条海蛇。他拔出了他的剑，名叫“H'Nightir”（意为“打击者”），并发表了他自己的演讲。他当然这么做了。
And he says, they may have more men, but it is fate that decides victory, not numbers. I swear that I will not flee from this fight. I will triumph or I will die. And all his men assemble. It's got his great lieutenant standing at his side who obviously is called Bjorn the bear. He's there. Doesn't Bjorn mean bear? Yeah. Well, yeah, it's just a tautology, but I mean, you know, it's there to, if this, don't forget the Slav mercenaries there. They might not know that Tom.
他说：“他们可能人多势众，但决定胜利的是命运，而不是人数。我发誓我不会逃避这场战斗。我将凯旋，或者我将战死。”他所有的手下都集结起来。他身边站着他的伟大副官，显然名叫“熊”比约恩（Bjorn the bear）。他在那儿。比约恩不就是“熊”的意思吗？嗯，是的，这只是一种同义反复，但我的意思是，你知道，为了，别忘了那里的斯拉夫雇佣兵。他们可能不知道这一点，汤姆。
Yeah, fair enough. It needs to be explained. It's also got a kind of Lancelot character who's called Roggenvald Bruceson, who's the son of the Earl of Orkney. You're a big fan of Orkney, aren't you? Yeah, well because the Earls of Orkney carry on being Vikings, you know, deep into the Middle Ages. So he's there, Roggenwald, and everyone should remember him because he'll be important in this story. But Harold, what about Harold? Olaf says, I do not think my brother Harold should be in the battle for his still a child. Certainly I should be in the battle for I am not too weak to handle
是的，有道理。这需要解释。这里还有一个类似兰斯洛特（Lancelot）的角色，名叫罗根瓦尔德·布鲁瑟松（Roggenvald Bruceson），他是奥克尼伯爵（Earl of Orkney）的儿子。你是奥克尼的超级粉丝，对吧？是的，因为奥克尼伯爵们一直都是维京人，你知道，一直延续到中世纪晚期。所以他在那儿，罗根瓦尔德，每个人都应该记住他，因为他在这个故事中很重要。但是哈拉尔呢？哈拉尔怎么样？奥拉夫说：“我认为我的兄弟哈拉尔不应该参加战斗，因为他还是个孩子。”“我当然应该参加战斗，因为我并不虚弱到无法挥舞
a sword and if necessary you can tie my hand to the hilt. That's what he says. He's stout and manly. He did not speak like that. So anyway, this is the first time that he comes out with one of his poems in the face of death. He says, my arm is wing while I shall stand. I will hold good with heart and hand. My mother's eye shall joy to see a battered bloodstained shield from me. There's no doubt I think in any listener's mind that this absolutely happened. So at about one o'clock according to the sagas these two lines advance on each other. Thorio the Hound is shouting, Olaf is shouting, they is shouting, the tension mounts, it's very Bernard Cornwell,
一把剑，如果有必要，你可以把我的手绑在剑柄上。”他是这么说的。他健壮且有男子气概。他可没这么说。不管怎样，这是他在面对死亡时第一次吟诵出他的诗句之一。他说：“只要我站着，我的手臂就在振翅。我将用心和手坚守。我母亲的眼看到我带着沾满鲜血的盾牌，定会充满喜悦。”任何听众都不会怀疑这绝对发生了。因此，大约在一点钟，根据传奇故事，这两支队伍向彼此推进。猎犬托里尔在大喊，奥拉夫在大喊，他们在呐喊，紧张局势升级，非常符合伯纳德·康沃尔（Bernard Cornwell）的风格，
and then the two lines crash together. And sort of trying to work out from the sagas, which as we said, written much later with masses of kind of fictionalisation and back projection, Olaf's men are almost certainly more skilled, more experienced than all these farmers and peasants. So when the sagas say they made initial headway, that's very plausible. But over time, the sheer weight of numbers, four to one, tells against them. So in King Harold's saga, which is part of a big cycle called Heimskringler, says, the
然后两支队伍猛烈撞击在一起。试图从传奇故事中理清头绪——正如我们所说，这是后来写的，带有大量的虚构化和倒填年代——奥拉夫的手下几乎可以肯定比所有这些农夫和农民更有技术、更有经验。因此，当传奇故事说他们取得了初步进展时，这是非常可信的。但随着时间的推移，四比一体量上的绝对人数优势对他们不利。因此，《哈拉尔国王传奇》（King Harold's saga）是被称为《海姆斯kringla》的大型循环的一部分，其中说道：“农民
peasant army pushed on from all quarters. Those in front hewed down with their swords, those behind thrust with their spears, and those in the rear shot arrows, cast spears, and threw stones, hand axes, or sharp stakes. Soon many men began to fall. So in other words, Olaf is very embattled. And Harold. And then, remember you said Tom, the heavens proclaimed their verdict. As is oddly so often the way in decisive battles
军队从四面八方推进。前面的用剑砍杀，后面的用长矛突刺，后方的则射箭、投矛，并抛掷石头、手斧或尖桩。很快许多人开始倒下。”换句话说，奥拉夫陷入了重围。而哈拉尔。然后，还记得你说的吗，汤姆？上苍宣告了他们的判决。正如历史上的决定性战役中往往不可思议的那样，
in history, guess what happens? There is a total eclipse. So we're told the sagas say, the sky and sun became red and then as black as night. And to read from a thrilling version of this story for younger readers, blood-curdling roars rose from the peasant army, the gods had spoken, the king must die. Now they surged forward emboldened triumphant, closing in on their former master, their faces twisted with demonic rage. They also definitely happened. So a very prosaic version of what happens next is basically the peasant armies weather the initial surge.
你猜怎么着？发生了日全食。所以我们被告知，传奇故事说，天空和太阳变红了，然后变得像黑夜一样黑。为了给年轻读者朗读这个故事的一个惊心动魄的版本：“毛骨悚然的咆哮声从农民军队中升起，诸神已经发话，国王必须死。”现在他们士气大振、气势汹汹地涌上前去，逼近他们以前的主人，他们的脸上带着恶魔般的愤怒扭曲着。这也是绝对发生过的。接下来发生的事情的一个非常平淡的版本基本上是，农民军队经受住了最初的冲击。
Olaf is outnumbered, his men are cut down, his standard bearer is cut down, drops the sea serpent banner, the morale breaks, people start running and at some point Olaf himself is slaughtered among the piles of bodies. But the sagas tell a very exciting story. So basically all boils down to this duel between Olaf and Thorir the Hound. He lands this fantastic blow on Thorir, he slashes at him, but Thorir is wearing that Sami reindeer skin coat. It was as dust flew from this coat and Olaf's sword just glances off it. And then Thorstein the ship, hacks at Olaf's leg with his axe. Olaf falls
奥拉夫寡不敌众，他的手下被斩杀，他的旗手被砍倒，丢下了海蛇旗，士气崩溃，人们开始逃跑，在某个时刻，奥拉夫本人也在尸堆中被屠杀。但传奇故事讲述了一个非常激动人心的故事。所以基本上这一切都归结为奥拉夫和猎犬托里尔之间的这场决斗。他向托里尔发起了一次惊人的攻击，他向他猛砍，但托里尔穿着那件萨米驯鹿皮外套。灰尘从这件外套上飞扬起来，奥拉夫的剑只是从上面擦过。然后造船匠托斯汀用斧头砍向奥拉夫的腿。奥拉夫倒在
over a boulder, which apparently you can still see on the field, called Olaf's stone. And you were driving very near the site. You opted not to go and look at it. I just don't like stones. I find them very dull. I find them disappointing. And also I had a brilliant image in my mind of this battle. Yeah, you didn't want to be disappointed. I didn't want to be disappointed by some prosaic stone. Anyway, Thorio the Hound. Remember he's got a magic spear.
一块巨石上，显然你仍然可以在战场上看到它，被称为“奥拉夫之石”。你开车离这个遗址很近。你选择不去看看它。我只是不喜欢石头。我觉得它们非常沉闷。我发现它们令人失望。而且我的脑海里有一个关于这场战役的绝妙画面。是的，你不想失望。我不想被某块平淡无奇的石头所失望。无论如何，猎犬托里尔。记住他有一把魔法长矛。
He plunges it up through Olaf's male shirt into his chest and then Kalf Arneson hits him in the neck and it's all over. For Olaf, that's all right. Because do you know who had appeared to Olaf while he was in Novgorod in a dream? Olaf Tryggvason. Oh no way, another Olaf. So it was Olaf Tryggvason who'd been Olaf the Stout's godfather. Right.
他把它猛地刺穿奥拉夫的锁子甲直插入他的胸膛，然后卡尔夫·阿尔内松击中了他的脖子，一切都结束了。对奥拉夫来说，这没关系。因为你知道谁在诺夫哥罗德（Novgorod）的一个梦中向奥拉夫显现过吗？奥拉夫·特里格弗森。哦，不会吧，另一个奥拉夫！所以那是奥拉夫·特里格弗森，他曾是勇敢的奥拉夫的教父。
He appeared to him and he said, look, don't worry. It's a glorious thing to die in battle. And then he vanished. Yeah. A Viking would know that though. They wouldn't need to be told. Yeah, but it would be a reassurance wouldn't it? If your godfather tells you.
他向他显现并说，听着，别担心。在战斗中死去是一件光荣的事。然后他就消失了。是的。不过维京人本就知道这一点。他们不需要别人告诉他们。是的，但这算是一种安慰，不是吗？如果你的教父对你这么说。
It would be a reassurance. You're right. That's true. That's true. Oh, that's nice. Anyway, he probably dies be a reassurance wouldn't it? If your godfather tells you. It would be a reassurance, you're right. That's true. That's true. Oh, that's nice. Anyway, he probably dies with a smile on his lips. I like to think of it. A grim smile. Now, almost everybody else we're told in the Sarkis is killed too, but not Harold.
这会是一种安慰。你说得对。确实如此。确实如此。哦，那挺好的。总之，他大概带着嘴角的微笑死去，这会是一种安慰，不是吗？如果你的教父对你这么说。这会是一种安慰，你说得对。确实如此。确实如此。哦，那挺好的。总之，他大概带着嘴角的微笑死去。我喜欢这么想。带着严峻的微笑。现在，萨迦告诉我们，几乎萨基尔的其他所有人也都阵亡了，但哈拉尔德没有。
Harold has somehow been wounded and put out of action, so he's kind of lying among the piles of bodies. And this guy, the Earl of Orkney's son, Roggenwald Brusseson, he helps him up and he drags him off the battlefield into the woods. Now Thoria the Hound is leading a kind of mopping up party to kill all the survivors, but they manage to evade him and they reach a woodsman's hut. And there the woodsman, a kindly forester, he takes them in and he says, listen, I will look after young Harold until he's well enough to travel. So I think it's probably fair to say at this point, this probably didn't happen. This feels a little bit fairy. It feels a
哈拉尔德不知怎么地受了伤，失去了战斗力，所以他算是躺在一堆尸体中间。然后这个人，奥克尼伯爵的儿子，罗根瓦尔德·布鲁瑟松，他扶起哈拉尔德，把他从战场拖进树林里。现在，“猎犬托里亚”正率领一支清剿小队去杀死所有幸存者，但他们设法避开了他，并来到了一间樵夫的小屋。在那里，樵夫，一位善良的护林员，收留了他们并说道：“听着，我会照顾年轻的哈拉尔德，直到他能独自旅行。”所以我想这时候说这可能没发生，大概算公允吧。这感觉有点童话。这给我的感觉
bit fairy tale to me, Tom. I mean, just to say also, there must have been enough survivors of the battle the next day to go and find Olaf's body. Yes. And spirit away. And they bury it in a sandy bank up river from Trondheim. And this is very important for the Christianization of Norway. Yeah. Because his death in that battle will come to be seen as a martyrdom. And his relics will become a great object of pilgrimage.
有点像童话，汤姆。我的意思是，顺便说一句，第二天战场上一定还有足够的幸存者去寻找奥拉夫的尸体。是的。然后秘密运走。他们把它埋在特隆赫姆上游的一个沙岸里。这对于挪威的基督教化非常重要。是的。因为他在那场战役中的死后来被视为殉道。他的遗物将成为朝圣的伟大对象。
Well, spoiler alert, he becomes a saint. Yeah. It's patron saint of Norway. We've had a few implausible saints on the podcast. He's definitely one of them. He's got church in London. Yeah. So Roggenvald goes off and he leaves Harold with this woodsman and days or weeks we don't know go by Harold's wounds heal and eventually the woodsman's son says, I
好吧，剧透预警，他成了一位圣人。是的。挪威的主旋律圣人。我们在播客里聊过一些不太靠谱的圣人。他绝对是其中之一。他在伦敦有教堂。是的。所以罗根瓦尔德离开了，把哈拉尔德留给了这位樵夫，几天还是几周我们不得而知，时间流逝，哈拉尔德的伤势愈合了，最终樵夫的儿子说，我
will guide you through the forests and over the mountains to Sweden. We're told that they stayed off the roads. They made their way through the woods and Harold wore a hooded cloak to hide his face. So he's very much kind of the ranger of the North. I like to think he travels under the name Stroyder or some such. Trotter. Yeah, Trotter.
将引导你穿过森林，翻越群山前往瑞典。我们得知他们避开了大路。他们穿过树林前行，哈拉尔德穿着连帽斗篷遮住脸。所以他非常像是北方的游侠。我喜欢想象他是以“斯特罗伊德”或类似的名字旅行的。流浪汉。是的，流浪汉。
That's Tolkien's original name. And he devises one of his lovely poems during the journey. Now from wood to wood I slink rated little, who knows, but I may win better fame later. I mean, it's not really a poem's go. It's probably not the best, but anyway, he's really tired. Yeah. He's just lost his brother. He's also a teenager.
那是托尔金最初的名字。他在旅途中创作了他可爱的诗歌之一。现在从一片树林到另一片树林，我蹑手蹑脚地潜行，谁知道呢，说不定我以后能赢得更好的名声。我的意思是，这其实算不上什么好诗。可能不是最好的，但不管怎样，他真的很累。是的。他刚失去了哥哥。他还是个十几岁的少年。
He's also a teenager. Come on, don't be hard. Yeah, I'm being too hard on him. I feel ashamed of myself now. Anyway, they go through all this wild country. He goes down into Sweden. The Baltic Sea lies beyond, he meets up with Roggenwald and that winter they hunker down brooding on their defeat. And then, says the saga, the spring came and Harald and
他还是个十几岁的少年。拜托，别对太苛刻了。对，我对他也太苛刻了。我现在为自己感到羞耻。总之，他们穿过所有这些荒野。他进入了瑞典，波罗的海就在前方，他与罗根瓦尔德会合，那个冬天他们在那里盘桓，沉浸在对失败的苦恼中。然后，萨迦记载，春天来了，哈拉尔德和
Roggenwald hired a ship and that summer they sailed east to the lands of the Rus'. Goodness, what a cliffhanger. So go east young man and that is what we will be doing after the break. Hello, I'm William Durrimple. And I'm Anita Arnand and we are the hosts of Empire also from Goalhanger. And we're here to tell you about our recent mini series that we've just done on the Troubles. And I'm Anita Anand and we are the hosts of Empire, also from Goalhanger. And we're here to tell you about our recent mini-series that we've just done on The Troubles. In it, we try to get to the very heart of the violent conflict in Northern Ireland that lasted from the 1960s all the way up to 1998. It's something that we both lived through and remember from our childhoods, but younger
罗根瓦尔德租了一艘船，当年夏天他们向东航海前往罗斯人的土地。天哪，真是个悬念。所以，年轻人向东去吧，而这正是我们休息之后要做的事情。大家好，我是威廉·达林普尔。我是安妮塔·阿南德，我们是《帝国》节目的主持人，该节目也来自高挂制作公司。我们在这里向大家介绍我们最近刚做完的关于北爱尔兰冲突的迷你剧。我是安妮塔·阿南德，我们是《帝国》节目的主持人，也来自高挂制作公司。我们在这里向大家介绍我们最近刚做完的关于北爱尔兰冲突的迷你剧。在剧中，我们试图触及北爱尔兰暴力冲突的核心，这场冲突从20世纪60年代一直持续到1998年。这是我们俩都经历过并从童年记忆中记得的事情，但更年轻的
listeners may not know anything about it. It's a time when there was division along religious and political lines, neighbors turned against each other, residential city streets became battlegrounds, thousands were killed, and the IRA bombed London. It seemed as if an end was out of reach, but in 1998, a peace process finally brought those 30 years of violence to an end. But the memory of the troubles is still present, not only within Northern Irish communities who experienced it, but in international relations and political approaches to peace.
听众可能对此一无所知。那是一个充满宗教和政治分歧的时代，邻居们反目成仇，居民区的街道成了战场，成千上万的人丧生，爱尔兰共和军轰炸了伦敦。冲突的终点似乎遥不可及，但到了1998年，和平进程终于结束了这30年的暴力。然而，北爱尔兰冲突的记忆依然存在，不仅存在于经历过它的北爱尔兰社区中，也存在于国际关系和对和平的政治方针中。
And new audiences are starting to understand this national trauma through films like Belfast and kneecap and TV shows like Derry Girls. In fact, our guest on the mini-series is Patrick Radden-Keefe. Now, he's the author of the non-fiction book that inspired the hit TV drama Say Nothing. It's one of my favourite books. It's, I think, the kind of inkhole blood for our generation, extraordinary work of nonfiction. To hear the full series, just search Empire wherever you get your podcasts. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We're in the midst, literally, of a saga. The 16-year-old Harold Hardrada is on the run. His brother Olaf the Stout has been killed.
新的观众开始通过《贝尔法斯特》和《死敌》等电影以及《德里女孩》等电视节目来了解这种国家创伤。事实上，我们在迷你剧中的嘉宾是帕特里克·拉登·基夫。他是启发了热门电视剧《无声言欢》的纪实文学作品的作者。这是我最喜欢的书之一。我认为它是我们这一代人的某种墨血，是一部非凡的纪实文学作品。要想收听完整系列，只需在您获取播客的任何地方搜索“帝国”。哈喽，欢迎回到《历史的剩余部分》。我们正置身于一部萨迦之中。16岁的哈拉尔德·哈德拉达正在逃亡。他的哥哥“刚毅者”奥拉夫已经被杀。
He's being hunted. He and his friend Rognvald have taken ship from the Swedish coast into the freezing waters of the Baltic. They have their Rangers hoods over their heads. Dominic, where are they going? So for the last 200 odd years, the Vikings have been going east as much as they've been going west. They've been sailing across the Baltic and the Gulf of Finland towards now Russia, Estonia, and Latvia. We did a couple of episodes about this in the early days of The Rest is History,
他正在被人追捕。他和他的朋友罗根瓦尔德从瑞典海岸乘船驶入波罗的海冰冷的水域。他们的头上戴着游侠的兜帽，多米尼克，他们要去哪里？所以，在过去的200多年里，维京人向东去的频率和他们向西去的不相上下。他们一直横渡波罗的海和芬兰湾，驶向现在的俄罗斯、爱沙尼亚和拉脱维亚。我们在《历史的剩余部分》早期做过几期关于这个主题的节目，
but just to remind people, the Vikings would head up the rivers, they'd carry furs and slaves, they'd go deep into Eastern Europe, and then they would make their way through the river network to the Black Sea and then south to Constantinople. And over these 200 years, they have built a chain of trading stations and forts and settlements stretching for 1,300 miles. And this becomes known as the Kingdom of Cities, Garderike, but it's better known today as the Land of Cities, Garda Ricae, but it's better known today as the Land of the Rus'. That word probably, there's lots of academic arguments about it which we talked about before, but it probably comes from an Old Norse term that means Roas because they
但为了提醒大家，维京人会逆流而上，他们携带毛皮和奴隶，深入东欧腹地，然后通过河流网到达黑海，再向南到达君士坦丁堡。在这200多年里，他们建立了一连串绵延1300英里的贸易站、堡垒和定居点。这就成了被称为“城市之国”的加尔达里基，但今天它更为人所知的名字是罗斯人的土地。这个词可能——学术界对此有很多争论，我们以前讨论过——但它大概源于一个古诺斯语词汇，意思是“划船者”，因为他们
often rowed down these or up these rivers. And obviously it's from that that we get Ruthenia, Russia, Belarus and so on and so forth. Now we can pretty much guess which way Harold went because there's a set route, there's kind of a highway. So he and Roggenwald would have crossed the Gulf of Finland to roughly near modern St. Petersburg and then they'd have taken the river Naver upstream to Lake Ladoga, Europe's largest freshwater lake. And here on the southern side is basically the gateway to the wild east, which is a place called Staraya Ladoga, which is this sort of, it is like a wild west town. And you mentioned
经常划船顺流或逆流而上。显然，鲁特尼亚、俄罗斯、白俄罗斯等等都是由此而来的。现在我们基本可以猜到哈拉尔德走的是哪条路，因为有一条固定的路线，类似于一条高速公路。所以他和罗根瓦尔德会穿过芬兰湾，大致到达现代圣彼得堡附近，然后他们会逆涅瓦河而上，到达欧洲最大的淡水湖——拉多加湖。这里南侧基本上就是通往蛮荒东方的门户，一个叫做斯塔拉亚拉多加的地方，这是一种，它就像一个狂野的西部小镇。你提到了
Neil Price, Tom, the great historian of the Vikings, he calls it a muddy riverine deadwood with greater ethnic variety plus swords and a multitude of gods. That's such a great description. And I mean, the context, the rivers and the network of forts, there is a sense beyond it of a kind of fantasy world, isn't there? Completely. Where, you know, there are dragons and I think men who have mouths between their nipples and all that kind of stuff.
尼尔·普赖斯，汤姆，伟大的维京人历史学家，他称之为“一片泥泞的河边死木，有着极大的种族多样性，外加刀剑和众多的神祇”。这真是个绝妙的描述。我的意思是，背景，河流和堡垒网，在其背后有一种幻想世界的感觉，不是吗？完全是这样。在那里，你知道，有龙，我想还有胸部之间长着嘴的人以及所有诸如此类的东西。
It is a kind of Dungeons and Dragons, terrifying dimension. Everything about this reminds me of, it feels so Tolkien-esque and the journey that Harold is going on is so fellowship of the ring and actually it's not a silly parallel because obviously Tolkien is basing his stories on this and that does capture, as you say, how they viewed the world because at the end of it are these shining cities of the Eastern Roman Empire and the Caliphate and whatnot with so much wealth and so much to them, so much mystery and splendor beyond anything they would see in Norway.
这是一种“龙与地下城”式的可怕维度。这一切都让我想起，它感觉太有托尔金风格了，哈拉尔德正在进行的旅程就像《魔戒现身》一样，实际上这并不是一个愚蠢的类比，因为显然托尔金的故事就是以此为基础的，正如你所说，这确实捕捉到了他们如何看待世界，因为在这条路的尽头，是东罗马帝国和哈里发国等闪闪发光的城市，那里有如此多的财富，如此多的事物，有远超他们在挪威所能见到的神秘与辉煌。
But also on the way kind of strange cities. Harold goes to Novgorod, which we've already mentioned, literally Newcastle. And this is a town made so completely out of wood that even the documents that have survived consist of birch bark. And again, that must have seemed an extraordinary place to anyone visiting it. Yeah. They've moved 150 miles down through the rivers to Novgorod. Again it's a tough place.
但沿途也有一些奇怪的城市。哈拉尔德去了我们已经提到过的诺夫哥罗德，字面意思就是“新堡”。这是一座完全用木头建造的城镇，以至于连幸存的文件都由桦树皮组成。同样，对于任何造访它的人来说，那一定是一个非凡的地方。是的。他们顺着河流下行150英里来到了诺夫哥罗德。这也是个艰难的地方。
It's kind of Wild West type place, but as you say, welcome back to the rest of history streets are we are in the way on the marshes and whatnot. Then they cross again with their canoes probably Lake Ilman. They would have had to drag the canoes or the barges through the woods for hundreds of miles when they're crossing from river to river or crossing around rapids and whatnot. It's risky. If you think about the fellowship of the ring, when they're going through the woods and stuff, being chased by orcs. It's got that feel to it because there are bandits in the woods.
这是一种狂野西部风格的地方，但正如你所说，欢迎回到历史的街道，我们正走在沼泽地之类的地方。然后他们很可能再次乘独木舟横渡伊尔门湖。当他们从一条河穿到另一条河，或者绕过急流险滩时，他们必须把独木舟或驳船拖过几百英里的树林。这很危险。如果你想想《魔戒现身》里，当他们穿过树林之类的，被半兽人追赶。它确实有那种感觉，因为树林里有强盗。
There are Slav tribes. I wouldn't have enjoyed it. Wouldn't have been a rest of history tour vibe, would it? And then at last, you know, they must have gone round a bend in the river and they see the walls of Keev, must have gone round a bend in the river and they see the walls of Kiev, which is built on bluffs above the river Dnieper. And Kiev, or Kiev, depending on what you call it, according to legend, it had been founded centuries earlier by three Slavic brothers and then taken over by Vikings called Ascald
有斯拉夫部落。我可不会喜欢。不会有“历史之旅”的氛围，对吧？然后终于，你知道，他们一定绕过了河的一个弯道，看到了基辅的城墙，一定绕过了河的一个弯道，看到了基辅的城墙，这座城市建立在第聂伯河上方的峭壁上。根据传说，基辅，或者叫基辅，取决于你怎么叫它，几个世纪前由三个斯拉夫兄弟建立，然后在公元860年代被名为阿斯科尔德
and Deer in the eight sixties. And it ends up effectively becoming the capital of this very loose state called Kievan Rus. This is the state from which as Vladimir Putin would be the first to tell you both Ukraine and Russia trace their kind of national lineage. The Grand Princes of Kiev had been Christians since 988 and that was when a guy called Volodymyr or Vladimir the Great converted to Christianity. And the fact that he's doing that tells you something about their strategic position because for them the great superpower is what would have called itself at the time the Roman Empire, the empire based in Constantinople. And Volodymyr had
和迪尔的维京人占领。它最终实际上成了这个非常松散的名为基辅罗斯的国家的首都。正如弗拉基米尔·普京会第一个告诉你的一样，乌克兰和俄罗斯都是从这个国家追溯他们的民族血统的。基辅的大公们自988年以来就一直是基督徒，当时一个叫沃洛迪米尔或伟大的弗拉基米尔的人皈依了基督教。他这样做的事实向你说明了他们的战略地位，因为对他们来说，伟大的超级大国是当时自称为罗马帝国的国家，那个以君士坦丁堡为中心的帝国。而沃洛迪米尔
married the emperor's daughter Anna, a massive figure in the history of the Christianization of the Rus, and it's probably their son, we can't be entirely certain about his parentage, but it's their son Yaroslav, who is now the Grand Prince of rules in Kiev as a Christian. So in that sense, you could say they're not so different from the warlords in Scandinavia who are also becoming Christian. Well, you know, who they remind me much more of is actually the Norman dukes. Right. Yeah.
娶了皇帝的女儿安娜，这是罗斯基督教化历史上的一个庞大人物，而这大概是他们的儿子——我们无法完全确定他的血统，但这是他们的儿子雅罗斯拉夫，他现在作为一名基督徒在基辅统治着罗斯大公国。所以从这个意义上说，你可以说他们与斯堪的纳维亚半岛那些同样在皈依基督教的军阀并没有太大区别。嗯，你知道，他们更让我想起的是诺曼公爵。没错。是的。
Because similarly there's that issue of a Viking polity that has becoming so influenced by the Christian power on its doorstep. Historians at this point are debating, are they still Scandinavian? They're adopting the language. So Yaroslav, he is a Viking descent, right? But his name is Slavic name. So it's very similar to debates that we've been having about the Norman Dukes. Are they Scandinavian?
因为类似地，存在着一个维京政体受到其家门口的基督教力量如此深远影响的问题。历史学家此时正在辩论，他们还是斯堪的纳维亚人吗？他们在采用这门语言。所以雅罗斯拉夫，他是维京血统，对吧？但他的名字是斯拉夫名字。所以这与我们一直在讨论的关于诺曼公爵的争论非常相似。他们是斯堪的纳维亚人吗？
Are they French? What are they? I think it's a really nice comparison. I think the difference is that Normandy is more, obviously much smaller and more focused and more coherent and more militarily progressive as it were than Kievan Rus'. It's such an interesting and strange place, I think. So when Harold arrived, Kiev at that point must have been by far the biggest and most awe-inspiring place you'd ever seen. Maybe 50,000 people lived there, so a lot bigger than say London at the same time.
他们是法国人吗？他们是什么？我认为这是一个非常好的比较。我认为不同之处在于，诺曼底显然要小得多，而且比基辅罗斯更集中、更连贯，军事上也更进步，可以说是这样。我认为这是一个非常有趣且奇怪的地方。所以当哈拉尔德抵达时，那时的基辅一定是你所见过的最大、最令人敬畏的地方。那里可能住着5万人口，所以比同时代的伦敦要大得多。
And also very closely modeled on Constantinople, right? So it's a kind of prefiguring of the great city, the golden city of Caesar that he will be reaching in due course. Exactly. So we know to give people a sense of what Kiev was like, all kinds of barges, people trading everything from silk to slaves to Grain to amber and honey and furs all the products of the north There was a lower town at the bottom of the hill called Podil and they would go up through the kind of past the cottages And then you've got this huge ramparts You have this topped with kind of white painted oak palisades
而且它也是高度模仿君士坦丁堡的，对吧？所以这是他日后将到达的伟大城市、凯撒的黄金城市的一种预示。完全正确。所以我们知道，为了让人们对基辅的面貌有个概念，各种驳船，人们交易着从丝绸到奴隶、从谷物到琥珀、蜂蜜和毛皮等北方的一切产品。山脚下有一个名为波多尔的下城，他们会穿过这些小屋。然后你会看到巨大的城垣，
three massive gates, one called the Polish gate, Jewish gate and the Golden gate. I mean, as you said, Tom, modeled on the gates in Constantinople, the Golden gate has its own chapel on the top of it and a kind of gilded dome. And this is the great entrance point to Kiev. And this great kind of fortress, again, I guess, a point of comparison with the Normans is the use of a fortified stronghold to intimidate the locals, to prey on them.
上面顶着涂成白色的橡木栅栏，三个巨大的城门，分别叫波兰门、犹太门和金门。我的意思是，正如你所说，汤姆，模仿自君士坦丁堡的城门，金门的顶端有它自己的一个小礼拜堂和一个镀金的圆顶。这是通往基辅的伟大入口。而这个宏伟的堡垒，同样，我想，与诺曼人的一个对比点是利用坚固的据点来恐吓当地人，掠夺他们。
Yeah. And it's a very predatory state, isn't it? Yeah. And the Citadel does have something in common with the kind of Norman castle. So the Citadel was called the Detonates. It's a little bit like a Kremlin, huge walls, impregnable to attack. Inside, you've got churches, you've got the kind of palace quarter, all of that kind of stuff.
是的。这是一个非常具有掠夺性的国家，不是吗？是的。而且这座城堡确实与诺曼式的城堡有某些共同点。所以城堡被称为“杰托内茨”。它有点像克里姆林宫，有巨大的城墙，攻击无法攻破。里面有教堂，有宫殿区，以及所有诸如此类的东西。
And it's there that you would, you know, if you wanted an audience with the Grand Prince Yaroslav, it's there that he would receive you. So according to the sagas, Harold and Roggenwald go in to see Yaroslav. He's now in his fifties. He's probably, as I said, the son of Grand Prince Volodymyr and his wife Anna. He is a man absolutely drenched in blood. He has fought this massive war against all his brothers. He's got about 500 brothers, hasn't he?
如果你想求见雅罗斯拉夫大公，你就是在那里受到他的接见。所以根据萨迦，哈拉尔德和罗根瓦尔德进去拜见雅罗斯拉夫。他现在五十多岁了。正如我所说，他很可能是大公沃洛迪米尔和他的妻子安娜的儿子。他是一个浑身浴血的人。他与他所有的兄弟打过这场大规模的战争。他大约有500个兄弟，不是吗？
Forty brothers. He's killed most of them. Well, there's one who gets chased into Poland, is it? And he, he dies a lunatic there, stabbing with a sword at, at empty air. Yeah. And a kind of terrifying sense that Yaroslav, even when he's not there, is haunting this poor brother's imaginings. Well, Yaroslav is a very impressive man. So later chroniclers called him Yaroslav the wise, though at the time people called him Yaroslav the lame because he'd got a limp from battle.
四十个兄弟。他杀死了他们中的大多数。嗯，有一个被追赶到波兰，是吗？他在那里像个疯子一样死去，用剑刺向空无一人的空气。是的。一种可怕的感觉，雅罗斯拉夫即使不在那里，也萦绕在这个可怜兄弟的幻想中。嗯，雅罗斯拉夫是一个非常了不起的人。所以后来的编年史家称他为“智者雅罗斯拉夫”，尽管当时的人们称他为“跛子雅罗斯拉夫”，因为他在战斗中留下了跛足。
And Tom, in 2008, a TV poll of two and a half million Ukrainians crowned him the greatest Ukrainian in history. Yeah, well he is. I think he's amazing. So there's also the amazing story that his enemies, his brothers and everything are on the far side of, I guess, the Dnieper or one of the great rivers and they're screaming abuse at him and they're the first to call him the lame. And Yaroslav is furious about this.
汤姆，在2008年，一项有两百五十万乌克兰人参与的电视民意调查将他评为历史上最伟大的乌克兰人。对，他确实是。我认为他太棒了。所以还有一个惊人的故事，他的敌人，他的兄弟们和其他所有人都在第聂伯河或其中一条大河的对岸，他们向他尖叫着辱骂，他们是第一批叫他跛子的人。雅罗斯拉夫对此大发雷霆。
And then the river ices over, Yaroslav crosses even with his limp, slaughters the lot of them. Of course he does. He's the man that I would take shelter with in Harold's predicament and it obviously works out very well for him. So Yaroslav, he's this blend, as you said, of Viking, Roman and Slav, Slavic name. His wife is the daughter of the Swedish king Ingegird and I think it's very unclear but I think she's a distant relative in some way of Harold's brother, his late brother Olaf. So he can kind of claim kin. Exactly.
然后河面结冰了，雅罗斯拉夫带着他的跛足也过了河，把他们杀了个精光。他当然会这么做。在哈拉尔德的困境中，他是我愿意与之避难的人，显然这对他非常有利。所以雅罗斯拉夫，正如你所说，他是维京、罗马和斯拉夫的混合体，有着斯拉夫名字。他的妻子是瑞典国王英格格尔德的女儿，虽然很不确定，但我认为她在某种程度上是哈拉尔德已故的哥哥奥拉夫的远亲。所以他可以算作亲戚。完全正确。
And as we said, he's also within what they would have called the Roman orbit. So his mother probably Roman and he's just started work on St Sophia. So Hagia Sophia. Exactly. It's first cathedral modeled on the original in Constantinople. And we are told by King Harold's saga he gave Harold and Roggenwald a very friendly reception, he loves a Scandinavian mercenary. Who doesn't? And so for the next two years Harold will serve in the Grand Prince's
正如我们所说，他也处于他们所谓的罗马势力范围内。所以他的母亲很可能是罗马人，他刚刚开始修建圣索菲亚大教堂。也就是圣索菲亚。完全正确。它是模仿君士坦丁堡原型的第一座大教堂。而根据《哈拉尔德国王萨迦》的记载，他对哈拉尔德和罗根瓦尔德给予了非常友好的接待，他非常喜欢斯堪的纳维亚雇佣兵。谁不喜欢呢？所以在接下来的两年里，哈拉尔德将在大公的
army. So this is really his military apprenticeship. So what is he? This is between the ages of let's say 17, 18? Yeah 17, 18, 19, this is what his military apprenticeship. So what does he, this is between the ages of, let's say 17, 18. Yeah. 17, 18, 19. This is what he's doing. And we get some sense, very vague of what kind of things he's doing. So we know that around this time, Kievan Rus is fighting against the Poles. So the Poles are a Slav kingdom that have expanded from around Poznan and they've
军队中服役。所以这真的是他的军事学徒期。那么他是什么？这是在大约17、18岁之间？对，17、18、19岁，这就是他的军事学徒期。那么他是，这在大约17、18岁之间。对。17、18、19岁。这就是他在做的事情。我们对他在做什么有了非常模糊的了解。所以我们知道，大约在这个时候，基辅罗斯正在与波兰人作战。所以波兰人是一个从波兹南一带扩张开来的斯拉夫王国，他们
been pushing East into what's now Belarus and Western Ukraine and now Yaroslav is pushing back through the woods. So we get these little hints, very fragmentary, from what Snorri Sturluson says, Harald Scalds, his kind of poets, his praise singers. So there's a guy called Fyodor Arneson who's quoted by Snorri Sturluson. He says, the leaders fought side by side, their troops in a fighting wedge, they drove the Slavs to defeat and showed the Poles little mercy. So we can only kind of glimpse these very mercilessly. But staining the snows red.
一直在向东推进到现在的白俄罗斯和西乌克兰，现在雅罗斯拉夫正通过树林反击。所以我们从斯诺里·斯图尔松的话中得到了这些零星的、非常破碎的暗示，斯诺里提到了哈拉尔德的斯卡尔德诗人，也就是他的赞美歌手。斯诺里·斯图尔松引用了一个叫费奥多尔·阿内森的人的话。他说，首领们并肩作战，他们的军队排成战斗楔形，他们将斯拉夫人击败，对波兰人毫不留情。所以我们只能非常无情地瞥见这些。但把雪染红了。
Exactly. And then the other one is they definitely fought a people called the Petrineggs. Oh, they're terrifying. They're like step nomads, aren't they, from Central Asia? They are always turning skulls into cups, aren't they? They are. So Yaroslav's grandfather, they'd beheaded him, they'd lined his skull with gold and used it as a wine goblet. And what the Rus will do is they will transport their troops along the rivers and then go
完全正确。然后另一个是他们绝对和一支叫做佩切涅格人的民族打过仗。噢，他们太可怕了。他们就像中亚的草原游牧民族，对吧？他们总是把头骨做成杯子，不是吗？他们确实如此。所以雅罗斯拉夫的祖父，他们砍下了他的头，用黄金镶嵌他的头骨，把它当做酒杯。而罗斯人会做的是，他们会用船只运送军队，然后去
and fight these guys and try to avoid fighting them in an open step ground because they're the petunix are unbeatable with their cavalry. So they try to draw them into the woods and fight them there. There's all kinds of stuff in the saga saying Harold loves this and he's absolutely brilliant at it. Another one of his scouts, a guy called Bolverk wrote these lines about Harold. Kind of looking back later on, he said, our brave king is to the Ruslands gone braver than he on earth. There's none. His sharp sword will carve many a feast for wolf and Raven in the East. Do you know, I think the rhyme scheme makes it slightly less impressive.
和这些家伙战斗，并尽量避免在开阔的草原上与他们战斗，因为佩切涅格人的骑兵是无敌的。所以他们试图把他们引诱到树林里并在那里战斗。萨迦里有各种各样的说法，说哈拉尔德喜欢这样，而且他在这方面极其出色。他的另一个侦察兵，一个叫博尔韦克的人写下了这些关于哈拉尔德的诗句。后来回想起来，他说，我们勇敢的国王去了罗斯地，世上没有比他更勇敢的人。他在东方用利剑为狼和渡鸦雕刻了许多盛宴。你知道，我觉得押韵方案让它稍微没那么震撼了。
Do you think so? Yeah, I do. So by the time he's about 18 or 19, Harold is promoted to captain of the guard, the guard we call the Drujina. about 18 or 19 Harold is promoted to captain of the guard. The guard were called the Drujjina and we know from the Arab traveller Ibn Fadlan that if you became one of the King's companions you would sort of feast with him in his hall and you would be given your own slave girl to wait on you, a quote, to wash his head and to prepare food and drink and another slave girl to serve as your
你这么觉得吗？是的，我确实这么觉得。所以到他大约18、19岁时，哈拉尔德被晋升为卫队队长，我们称之为“德鲁日纳”的卫队。大约18、19岁时，哈拉尔德被晋升为卫队队长。卫队被称为“德鲁日纳”，我们从阿拉伯旅行家伊本·法德兰那里得知，如果你成为了国王的同伴之一，你就会在国王的大厅里与他一同宴饮，并会被分配你自己的女奴来伺候你，原话是，“为他洗头并准备食物和饮料”，还有另一个女奴充当你的
concubine. So Harold doesn't want for female company at this point, though unfortunately these are slave girls. But he's after more. So he clearly sees himself as somebody who will return one day to claim the throne of Norway and succeed his brother and avenge his brother Olaf. And it is such a theme, isn't it, of this period? People being exiled and coming back over and over again. But to do that, he would obviously need Yaroslav's support. He would need to persuade the Grand Prince of Kiev to allow him to recruit troops, to give him troops, and he would really want
姬妾。所以哈拉尔德此时并不缺乏女性陪伴，尽管不幸的是这些都是女奴。但他在追求更多。所以他清楚地把自己视为一个终有一天会重返故土索取挪威王位、继承兄长并为哥哥奥拉夫报仇的人。这确实是这一时期的主题，不是吗？人们被流放然后一次又一次地回来。但要做到这一点，他显然需要雅罗斯拉夫的支持。他需要说服基辅大公允许他招募军队、给他军队，而且我认为他会极力想要
to strengthen his connection with Yaroslav, I think, as much as possible. And as luck would have it, Yaroslav has an eligible daughter. There's no way of dressing this up. When Harold arrived in Kiev, she was probably about six years old. So by the time he's made captain of the guard, she's probably about nine. And that's a point at which you would become betrothed. You wouldn't marry until you're mid-teens, but you might have been betrothed for several years.
尽可能加强他与雅罗斯拉夫的关系。真巧，雅罗斯拉夫有一个适龄的女儿。这没什么好掩饰的。当哈拉尔德抵达基辅时，她大概六岁左右。所以当他被册封为卫队队长时，她大概九岁。这是你可以订婚的时候。你不会在十几岁出头就结婚，但你可能会订婚好几年。
Her name is Elisif or in the Slavic Elizaveta. We have absolutely no knowledge of her inner life at all. There is an image of her, there's an 11th century fresco of her family in the Cathedral of St. Sophia in Kiev. But it's quite, I mean, some of the accounts I've read, people say, oh, she's obviously a very serious person, pale skinned and all this kind of thing. I'm like, this is obviously generic, orthodox image. You can't really interpret anything from this, but we know from the sagas, Harold goes to Yaroslav and he says, listen, you'll recall my distinguished lineage, you know, first hand of my prowess. Can I ask for your daughter's hand in marriage?
她的名字叫伊莉丝芙，在斯拉夫语中是伊莉莎维塔。我们对她的内心世界一无所知。关于她有一幅画像，基辅圣索菲亚大教堂里有一幅她11世纪家族壁画。但这相当，我的意思是，我读过的一些记载说，人们说，哦，她显然是一个非常严肃的人，皮肤白皙诸如此类。我觉得，这显然是千篇一律的正统圣像。你无法从中解读出任何东西，但我们从萨迦中得知，哈拉尔德去找雅罗斯拉夫说，听着，你还记得我显赫的家世，你亲眼见证了我的英勇。我能请求迎娶你的女儿吗？
us. Can I ask for your daughter's hand in marriage?" I think he responds quite nicely. He says, it's fair, it's a good match, but you have no means to support a royal wife since you have no lands of your own. So although I do not say yes, I do not say no either. One day I believe you will be a great man and when that day comes, you may ask me again. So the sagas say Harold walks away from Yaroslav's hall and he already knows what he's going to do. He needs a reputation to marry this girl and he needs money and there is one place you go to get both of those things. And this is the city that is really the dream, I think, of every Viking who goes east, which
我们。我能请求迎娶你的女儿吗？”我觉得他的回应相当得体。他说，这很公平，这是一场好姻缘，但你没有供养皇家妻子的手段，因为你没有自己的土地。所以虽然我没有说同意，但我也没有说不同意。我相信总有一天你会成为一个伟大的人，当那一天到来时，你可以再次向我求婚。所以萨迦说，哈拉尔德走出了雅罗斯拉夫的大厅，他心里已经清楚自己要做什么了。他需要名誉来娶这个女孩，他需要金钱，而有一个地方是你能同时得到这两样东西的。这就是这座真正成为所有向东的维京人梦想的城市，也就是
is this great city of Miklagard. Actually, literally, the great city. The great city, yeah. So Miklagard, some historians think the inspiration for Asgard, you know, for the City of the Gods. The descriptions are Asgard is golden, it's roof with precious metals, isn't it? It gleams with splendid palaces, it's encircled by a great wall. I mean that is a description of, well of Caesar's golden
伟大的城市米克拉加德。实际上，字面意思就是伟大的城市。伟大的城市，是的。所以米克拉加德，一些历史学家认为是阿斯加德（诸神之城）的灵感来源。那些描述是阿斯加德是金色的，它的屋顶镶嵌着贵重金属，不是吗？它闪烁着灿烂的宫殿，被一堵大城墙环绕。我的意思是，这正是对凯撒黄金
city. Exactly. So this city, Miclagard, the great city is Constantinople, the new Rome, by far the biggest city in Europe. So in the summer of 1034, Harold and some companions, we're told the suspiciously round number of 500 companions go out south down the Dnieper, very well traveled path, past the rapids of Zaporizhzhya to the Black Sea, down the Bosphorus, and then up the Golden Horn into the city of Constantine. born into the city of Constantine. Not an unfamiliar place for Norsemen to go. They've launched attacks, haven't they, in 860, 941, 944? They kind of initially introduced themselves by capturing monks and shooting arrows into their heads. Exactly.
城市的描述。完全正确。所以这座城市，米克拉加德，伟大的城市就是君士坦丁堡，新罗马，迄今为止欧洲最大的城市。所以在1034年的夏天，哈拉尔德和一些同伴——我们被告知是一个可疑的整数500个同伴——向南沿着第聂伯河出发，这是一条非常熟悉的路线，经过扎波罗热的急流来到黑海，顺着博斯普鲁斯海峡，再顺着金角湾进入君士坦丁堡城。进入君士坦丁堡城。对北欧人来说，这不是一个陌生的地方。他们在860年、941年、944年发动过袭击，不是吗？他们最初通过绑架僧侣并向他们头部射箭来介绍自己。完全正确。
The Romans had seen them off with a combination of Greek fire and icon intervention. They'd paraded with icons with magic powers, not magic powers, I should say, divine powers. Supernatural. Yep. And seen them off. So the historian Kat Jarman has a book called River Kings. You read that book, Tom?
罗马人结合了希腊火和圣像干预击退了他们。他们游行展示带有神奇力量的圣像——不是神奇力量，我应该说，是神圣的力量。超自然力量。是的。并把他们击退了。所以历史学家卡特·贾曼有一本书叫《河中之王》。你读过那本书吗，汤姆？
About following beads. Yeah, the amber. Yeah. And she has loads of stuff in there about what we know about customs. They're all kind of customs arrangements and special regulations for Norse travellers arriving in Constantinople. So he's not an incredibly unfamiliar figure. Well, there are two kinds, aren't there?
关于追随珠子的。是的，琥珀。是的。她里面有很多关于我们所知道的习俗的内容。这些都是针对抵达君士坦丁堡的北欧旅行者的习俗安排和特殊规定。所以他并不是一个极其陌生的人物。嗯，有两种人，不是吗？
There are people who are going to fight, but there are also merchants there. So skins, I think they're called. Exactly. He is not going to be doing that. No, he's going to fight. So for Harold, what is he 19 years old? This must have been an absolutely jaw-dropping experience. The Golden Horn, the huge walls, the markets, the bath houses, the Forum, the Hippodrome,
有要去战斗的人，但也有那里的商人。所以，我想他们被称为皮草商。完全正确。他可不是去干这个的。不，他是去战斗的。所以对哈拉尔德来说，他当时19岁？这一定是一次极其令人惊叹的经历。金角湾、巨大的城墙、市场、浴室、广场、竞技场、
the massive palace complex of the Caesars. I mean, we know there's the famous story about when emissaries from the Rus went into Hacchia Sophia, which was then 500 years old, and they said, we didn't know if we were in earth or in heaven, for surely there is no such magnificence or opulence anywhere in the world. Yeah, we cannot forget that beauty. Exactly. And actually that reflects a deeper picture or a wider picture, which is that actually the Byzantine Empire, the Eastern Roman Empire, for once it's actually doing pretty well.
凯撒宏伟的宫殿群。我的意思是，我们知道那个著名的故事：当罗斯的使者进入当时已有500年历史的圣索菲亚大教堂时，他们说：“我们不知道自己是在大地上还是在天堂，因为世上绝无如此宏伟或富丽堂皇之景。”是的，我们无法忘怀那种美。完全正确。而实际上这反映了一幅更深层或更广阔的画面，那就是实际上拜占庭帝国、东罗马帝国，这一次它的确过得相当不错。
It's at a kind of medieval peak under the Macedonian dynasty who are ruling it. They've crushed the Bulgars, they've recaptured a bit of territory in Syria, they've recaptured a bit of territory in Sicily and in Georgia. They're going through a kind of literary and artistic renaissance. So actually things are looking quite good for them and they're quite self-confident and quite buoyant. Now Harold will get very very involved in kind of Constantinople politics and we'll get on to that in the next episode but just to give listeners a sense of the picture, there has just been a change of Emperor at the top. So the Emperor in the early 1030s had been a guy called Romanus III, who was basically
在统治它的马其顿王朝统治下，它正处于中世纪的巅峰。他们粉碎了保加利亚人，在叙利亚收复了一点领土，在西西里和格鲁吉亚收复了一点领土。他们正在经历某种文学和艺术复兴。所以实际上他们的状况看起来相当不错，而且相当自信，相当意气风发。现在哈拉尔德将非常非常深地卷入君士坦丁堡的政治中，我们将在下一集中讨论这一点，但为了给听众一个整体的概念，高层的皇帝刚刚发生了更替。所以在1030年代初，皇帝是一个叫罗曼努斯三世的人，他基本上是
a bureaucrat. He was in his mid 60s and he was married to the Empress Zoe, born in the purple, so from the Imperial family. She's younger, she's in her mid 50s. And Zoe, I think it's fair to say is that she's a character, isn't she, Tom? Yeah, she is. She's a memorable character. We'll discuss her in more detail on Thursday.
一个官僚。他六十多岁，娶了出生于紫室、来自皇室家族的佐伊女皇。她比较年轻，五十多岁。而佐伊，我认为可以公平地说她是个很有个性的人，不是吗，汤姆？是的，她是。她是一个令人难忘的角色。我们将在周四更详细地讨论她。
She's blonde. She's very voluptuous. She's very clever. She's incredibly vain. She's always sort of taking strange potions and, and sort of smearing creams on herself, unguance, unguance. She loves an ungulent. Now she's been having an affair with a younger palace official called Michael. and sort of smearing creams on herself. Unguance. Unguance. She loves an ungulent.
她金发碧眼。她非常丰满。她非常聪明。她极其虚荣。她总是服用各种奇怪的药剂，并在自己身上涂抹乳霜、药膏、软膏。她喜欢软膏。现在她一直在和一个二十多岁、长相非常英俊的年轻宫廷官员米歇尔偷情。并在自己身上涂抹乳霜。药膏。软膏。她喜欢软膏。
Now she's been having an affair with a younger palace official called Michael, who's in his twenties, very good looking. And in April 1034, so just before Harold arrives in Constantinople, the emperor's officials, Romanus's officials came into his bathroom and found him dead in his bath, strangled probably, and almost all the sources say it was Michael who did it. He had murdered this bloke and he has now become Emperor because he's married Zoe and become Emperor himself, Michael the fourth. And actually the Empire is being run by his brother. Who's a tremendous figure. Inevitably a eunuch.
现在她一直在和一个二十多岁、长相非常英俊的年轻宫廷官员米歇尔偷情。在1034年4月，也就是哈拉尔德抵达君士坦丁堡前不久，皇帝的官员，罗曼努斯的官员走进他的浴室，发现他死在浴缸里，可能是被勒死的，几乎所有的消息来源都说是米歇尔干的。他谋杀了这个家伙，现在他成了皇帝，因为他娶了佐伊并自己成为了皇帝，也就是米歇尔四世。而实际上帝国是由他的兄弟在治理。这是一个了不起的人物。不出所料是个阉人。
Well you say inevitably. Yeah. I mean, it's quite odd that the brother of the emperor would be a eunuch, but actually it's the eunuch who had originally got Michael in. The eunuch comes first. Exactly. We will come to him because he's a great character. John the Orphanotrophus, I think is his name.
嗯，你说不出所料。是的。我的意思是，皇帝的兄弟是个阉人确实有点奇怪，但实际上正是这个阉人最初把米歇尔弄进宫的。阉人在前。完全正确。我们会谈到他，因为他是一个伟大的人物。我想他的名字叫“阉人供养者”约翰。
Anyway, he's running the show. Michael, this kind of handsome toy boy is now the emperor and Zoe is still on the scene as Empress. And it's fair to say, I think a nest of vipers, Tom, and I choose the serpentine analogy for good reason. Yeah. Because the serpents go all the way down into the bowels of the palace. They do indeed.
总之，他在掌控大局。米歇尔这个英俊的小白脸现在成了皇帝，而佐伊仍然作为女皇在场。可以公平地说，汤姆，这是一个毒蛇窝，我使用蛇类做比喻是有充分理由的。是的。因为群蛇一直延伸到宫殿的最深处。确实如此。
But for the time being, you know, Harold, there's no reason he should really worry about all this. He's just an obscure Scandinavian mercenary. His name will mean something to Scandinavians, but it won't really mean anything to the Romans. And he is heading not for the palace, well, not for the center of the palace, but for a building that may well adjoin it, which is the barracks of the most glamorous warriors in Christendom. And these are the Varangian Guard.
但就目前而言，你知道，哈拉尔德，他没有理由真正担心这一切。他只是一个名不见经传的斯堪的纳维亚雇佣兵。他的名字对斯堪的纳维亚人来说意味着什么，但对罗马人来说并没有什么真正的意义。他前往的不是宫殿，嗯，不是宫殿的中心，而是一座可能与其相邻的建筑，也就是基督教世界中最迷人的战士的军营。这就是瓦兰吉亚卫队。
warriors in Christendom. And these are the Varangian guard. So the Varangian guard, I mean, they're the sort of sexiest of all medieval elite warriors, aren't they? They are a bodyguard established in 988, at the point when Volodymyr the Great of Kiev had decided to embrace Christianity and to do this marriage deal with the emperors. And Volodymyr had sent, we're told, 6,000 Norse and Slavic mercenaries, who became known as Varangians after the Norse word var, which means oath. So they are literally called the oath keepers. And I think that when bands of Norse went southwards to begin with, it would be a kind of consortium. Exactly.
基督教世界中的战士。这就是瓦兰吉亚卫队。所以瓦兰吉亚卫队，我的意思是，他们是中世纪所有精锐战士中最性感的一群，不是吗？他们是一支成立于988年的卫队，当时基辅的伟大的弗罗迪米尔决定拥抱基督教，并与皇帝达成这桩婚姻交易。弗罗迪米尔派出了，我们被告知，6000名诺斯和斯拉夫雇佣兵，他们因诺斯语词汇var（意为誓言）而被称为瓦兰吉亚人。所以他们字面上的意思就是“守誓者”。我认为，当诺斯人成群结队向南出发时，最初它是一种联盟。完全正确。
So it's a band of Varangians who found Novgorod, for instance. Exactly. So the sort of the idea that you would swear an oath and you would become a kind of team. A blood brother. Exactly. These over time, we've now moved on sort of 40, 50 years from this, but they're still going and they've become a kind of special forces unit. So they will be sent across the empire to Syria, to Sicily, wherever, you know, to take part in sieges and stuff like that. Parachuting in.
所以是一群瓦兰吉亚人建立了诺夫哥罗德，例如。完全正确。所以那种你发誓并成为一个团队的想法。血兄弟。完全正确。随着时间的推移，我们现在已经从这一点前进了大约40、50年，但他们仍然在运转，并且已经变成了一种特种部队单位。所以他们将被派往帝国的各地，去叙利亚、西西里，无论哪里，去参与围城战之类的事情。空降。
Exactly. Most of them are Scandinavian, not all. So there are Anglo-Saxons and certainly later on. Well, there will be quite a few more in due course. And Slavs. They become famous. There are sort of hints of them in Roman sources. They are famous for drinking, for having double-headed axes, and general sort of Berserker ferocity, I think it's fair to say. And for scrawling graffiti in churches. The most famous relics of them are in Hacchia Sophia,
完全正确。他们大多数是斯堪的纳维亚人，但并非全部。所以也有盎格鲁-萨克森人，当然还有后来的。嗯，到时候会有相当多的人。还有斯拉夫人。他们出了名。罗马文献中对他们有某种暗示。他们以酗酒、使用双头斧和普遍的狂战士凶猛而闻名，我认为可以这样说。而且喜欢在教堂里乱涂乱解。他们最著名的遗迹在圣索菲亚大教堂里，
and there's a bit of graffiti that says Half Dan. In other words, a guardsman guarding the imperial family would have written basically Half Dan was here. And there were scrawled longboats, aren't there, in the upper would have written basically, Half-Dan was here. And there were scrawled longboats, aren't there, in the upper galleries? I mean, an amazing thing to see. We have a sense of them from picture stones on the island of Gotland and also things that have been found in graves in Scandinavia that they might have worn sort of baggy silk trousers and had kind of armour in rectangular little plates rather like step nomad kind of armour.
有一处涂鸦写着“哈夫丹”。换句话说，守卫皇室的卫兵基本上会写下“哈夫丹到此一游”。上层走廊里还有涂鸦的长船，不是吗？我的意思是，这是一件令人惊叹的事情。我们通过哥特兰岛上的图画石以及在斯堪的纳维亚墓穴中发现的东西对他们有了一定的了解，他们可能穿着某种宽大的丝绸裤子，并穿着类似草原游牧民族那种由小矩形板组成的盔甲。
And do you think when they go back to Scandinavia, they're baggy silk trousers? They're like teenagers from a gap year in India. Like you Tom after you went to India and you returned an Indian garb. Yeah. I guess maybe. Yeah, I think there's an element of that plus the French foreign legion. Yeah, they've seen things. All of that.
你觉得当他们回到斯堪的纳维亚时，他们穿着宽大的丝绸裤子吗？他们就像去印度间隔年的青少年。就像你汤姆，你去印度之后回来时穿着印度的长袍。是的。我想也许吧。是的，我认为其中包含一部分因素，再加上法国外籍军团。是的，他们见识过世面。所有这些。
And I mean, you don't come back from a gap year with your pockets loaded with gold. No, but these blokes absolutely do. So to be a Varangian guard, you were paid 40 gold solidi for a regular guardsman. And if you get to guard the Imperial family, you get 44 solidi. That's as much money, if not more than you would get from a really, really good Dane gelled payout in the West. And of course it's much more reliable. You basically signed a contract.
我的意思是，gap year（间隔年）结束时，你不可能口袋里揣满黄金回来。不，但这些家伙确实如此。因此，作为瓦兰吉亚卫队的一员，普通卫兵的薪水是40个金索利迪（solidi）。如果你去守护皇室，你就能得到44个索利迪。这笔钱即使不比西方那些极好的丹麦金（Danegeld）赔付更多，也至少同样丰厚。而且当然，它可靠得多。你基本上是签了合同的。
As long as you don't get killed. And gold is better than silver. Yeah, of course. Remember we had Eleanor Barrowclough on Talking About the Sagas. So in one of her books, I think it's Beyond the Northlands, she describes these people as strong, silent types dripping with gold, swayed in expensive fabrics and weighed down by top of the range weaponry. She compares them with the Rangers of the North in the Lord of the Rings. So you know the Rangers when they turn up in the Fellowship of the Ring, Aragorn and
只要你不被杀死。而且黄金比白银更好。是的，当然。还记得我们请埃莉诺·巴罗克劳夫（Eleanor Barrowclough）来谈论过《冰岛萨迦》吗？所以在她的一本书中，我想是《超越北方之地》（Beyond the Northlands），她将这些人描述为身强力壮、沉默寡言、浑身挂满黄金、身穿昂贵织物、身上挂着顶级武器的硬汉。她把他们与《指环王》中的北方游侠相提并论。所以你知道当游侠们出现在《护戒同盟》中时，阿拉贡和
whatnot, they're kind of these strong, silent, battle-hardened, mysterious figures behind their hoods with suspiciously fine swords. But not prone to berserk. No, I guess not. But we just don't see that. Seats of violence. I like to think it's happening off stage in Tolkien's world. Don't you?
诸如此类的人物，他们戴着兜帽，身后背着可疑的好剑，是一群坚强、沉默、饱经战火、神秘莫测的人物。但他们不会狂暴化。不，我想不会。但我们就是看不到这一点。暴力的基调。我喜欢认为这发生在托尔金世界的幕后。你不觉得吗？
Yeah, I suppose. The massacres of orcs or something. Yeah, I guess. All those little orc babies. Right, exactly. So, Harold, it makes complete sense that he will do this. If he is able to not get killed and to save his money, he will be able to go back to Kiev, a rich man, he'll be able to marry Elisif.
是的，我想是的。屠杀兽人什么的。是的，我猜。所有那些兽人小宝宝。对，没错。所以，对哈拉尔来说，他这么做完全合情合理。如果他能不被杀死并攒下钱，他就能带着巨额财富回到基辅，并能够娶埃莉西芙（Elisif）。
He'll have the blessing of the Grand Prince of Kiev, and then he can think about going back to Norway to reclaim his throne. So he goes to their barracks and we're told brilliantly that he signs on under an assumed name, very strider-like, and his name is Nordbricht, North Bright. That's what he chooses. And so Tom, he has joined the Varangian Guard and the stage is set for adventure. Ahead fly Sicily, Armenia, Jerusalem, the murder of an emperor, eye gouging and a terrifying encounter with a giant snake. But will Harold ever make it back to Avengers brother and reclaim his throne? Tom, will he put aside the Ranger and become who he
他将得到基辅大公的祝福，然后他就可以考虑回到挪威夺回他的王位。于是他去了他们的军营，我们得知了一个精彩的细节：他用一个化名签约，非常像神行客（Strider），他的名字叫诺德布里希特（Nordbricht），意为“北方之光”。这就是他的选择。所以，汤姆，他已经加入了瓦兰吉亚卫队，冒险的舞台已经搭好。前方将经历西西里、亚美尼亚、耶路撒冷、谋杀皇帝、挖眼酷刑以及与巨蛇的惊悚遭遇。但是哈拉尔最终能回到他哥哥的身边并夺回王位吗？汤姆，他会放下游侠的身份，成为他
was born to be? We'll find out next time. So exciting. So next time on The Rest is History, we continue the saga of Harold Ardralda with the return of the king and members of The Rest is History Club, those who belong to our own Varangian Guard, can hear that story right now. And if you are not a Varangian, if you're just a skin, a merchant, then you can change that. You can sign up at the restlesshistory.com. Alternatively, you can wait to hear it later in the week.
生来就要成为的人吗？我们下期揭晓。太令人兴奋了。所以下期《历史的剩余》（The Rest is History），我们将继续讲述哈拉尔·哈德拉达（Harold Hardrada）的传奇故事，随之回归的还有国王以及“历史的剩余”俱乐部成员——那些属于我们自己的瓦兰吉亚卫队成员，他们现在就可以听到这个故事。如果你不是瓦兰吉亚人，如果你只是个普通皮肤（skin）、一个商人，那么你可以改变这一点。你可以在 restlesshistory.com 上注册。或者，你也可以等到本周晚些时候收听。
But either way, we will be back with Varangian Fun and Games. Bye bye. Bye bye. Bye-bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但无论如何，我们都会带着瓦兰吉亚的趣味与游戏回归。再见。再见。再见。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。